Uh, hello.
Welcome to day three.
Welcome, welcome to day three.
I never expected to live this far, but here we are.
Day three of Minecraft Twitch Rivals!
Let's fucking go!
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
Give it up for day three!
Day fucking three!
Oh shit, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I already misspoke the rule.
Okay, so for those who don't know, today, they're enforcing rules more heavily.
So, other than the fact that we're not...
They're like, guys, they had like a...
Today, this morning, they had like...
They're enforcing...
They're like, we're gonna be enforcing rules now more strictly.
And then, so like other stuff, it's like understandable.
No metagaming, like no stream sniping, you know, stuff like that, that we don't do.
Um, and then they're like, I had no...
No mic spamming, like no playing copyright music.
Because remember yesterday, people were obnoxiously playing copyright music yesterday.
So they were like, no copyright music!
We're not allowed to like talk to people outside of the in-game voice chat, stuff like that.
Um, so because like people were talking, you know, people were interacting with like...
Apparently, some people were interacting on like Discord and stuff, like with Discord audio.
So like no voice proximity, which I was like, oh my god, that's so smart.
But also, oh my god, wait, that's cheating!
So they're enforcing that, but the one rule that stood out to me the most...
No profanity.
So...
So no more profanity for this bird.
So that was like one of the the five rules.
I don't know, five or six rules that they're trying to enforce.
Now, there was another one that interested me.
I'm not as like, isn't like, oh, I'm gonna do it.
But like one of them was like, uh, no, oh my gosh.
Okay, let me read it again.
I thought that rule was so interesting, because I'm like, wait, we're actually not allowed to do that?
Let me, let me find it again.
It was actually, I was like, what, what the heck?
See, I'm, I'm learning.
But one of them, oh my gosh, where is it?
Where's the general announcement?
Oh, yeah, uh, unfair competition, negative behavior!
And dishonest acts are strictly forbidden!
So that means no gaslighting!
Players are expected to maintain a positive attitude towards fellow competitors.
And organizers to ensure a friendly environment.
Okay, it doesn't say no gaslighting.
But there it says unfair competition and negative behavior and dishonest acts are strictly forbidden.
I assume that means you can't gaslight others.
I assume, I don't know if that's true or not.
But like, uh, but like, I assume that's what it means.
Because like, what does like, what does like, uh, what does like dishonest acts mean?
Or like, or like negative, like, what does that mean?
This is like that one guy that was like, this is the wrong house!
Does that count?
Like, is, remember when like, Gumi and I were running towards the house?
And then one of them was like, this, like, is, is fake comms considered dishonest?
Like, does that count?
I don't know!
But like, that rule is actually pretty freaking vague.
Okay, I had to...
That rule was pretty freaking vague.
So like, I couldn't really tell what that actually meant.
Also, apparently, you're allowed...
You're allowed to rat out other prop players if you're a prop.
And like, that's messed up.
That's so, like, why?
Like, who would want to be a prop at that point?
Like, just eliminate a fellow prop player.
Yeah, you're allowed to like, shout, like, rat other prop members out.
Okay, so the fourth game, the fourth...
Okay, wait, one, two...
Okay, sorry, the fifth game.
The fifth game is called, like, Duck Duck Curse or some shit.
I mean, some frick...
I'm trying, okay?
I'm trying really hard.
I'm not a Minecraft player, so that's built in.
Man, I'm an FPS gamer.
We've said, like, I've heard and said, like, so much profanity.
And I've heard so much worse.
Okay.
Anyway.
Anyway, so basically, it's like RNG, so we have to run around and find, like, curse dolls.
And then, we have to, like...
But the thing is, the curse doll can either be safe or a curse.
So, it's like RNG.
So you don't know if you're gonna get the curse or the safe doll.
And then, we find the curse doll, you have to run away.
Because, like, I assume they look like this.
I assume, because these look like curse dolls.
So, like, you have to, like, run away.
And if you get caught, you get eliminated.
Oh my gosh, if I get eliminated on the first game.
Oh my gosh.
Freedom.
I mean, it'd be fun if day four...
Anyway, freedom is so close.
Anyway, day...
Okay, game five...
Game five is 10 people will be eliminated.
But game six, 30 people will be eliminated.
Right now, players are arguing with the organizers on whether or not you should be allowed to rat out other prop players.
Because one of them was, like...
I saw people using the rules against the admins.
And was like, ratting other prop members is negative behavior.
So vague.
Like, that's what I'm saying.
Those rules are so goddamn vague.
So, like, I see, like, people in the server, the discord chat was like, that is negative behavior.
Because it's griefing other players.
So...
Um...
It's, like, dishonest.
It ruins competitive integrity.
So, like, the admins and, like, the players are, like, arguing right now about it.
That's why we're not starting it, I think.
I think...
There's 94 players?
Oh, that means, like, all of them are just admins.
I was gonna be like, how is there 94 players?
There should be only 80 players.
How is there, like, so many admins?
It's...
Not the competitive integrity.
That's why we're not starting it.
Because people are, like, arguing right now about the rules for the second game.
I mean, I mean, that's what I'm saying.
It's so vague.
Like, what counts as...
What counts as competitive and, like, what counts as negative behavior?
It's so goddamn vague.
uh Uh, oh, weird.
They're making changes to the launcher.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know.
Yeah, and apparently...
Okay, one other funny thing is that, uh, um, people were complaining about the copyright music that was being played yesterday.
Like, whoever that little hacker was that...
That that...
Um, because like apparently people like uploaded their bods and got copyright striked Yeah, like whoever, like whoever that was, I don't know if they're still in this lobby But people were complaining because they're like, we got a copyright strike because someone,
someone got like, um Someone, you know, people were playing copyright music So people were like, bro, I got a strike, bro, I got a claim, I can't monetize it So yeah, I thought that was, well, to me it was funny, but like obviously that sucks man
Like, that sucks bro, but like to me that was pretty funny
Alright, I guess, I guess we should, I guess we cannot take meds for a little bit But, where is everybody?
There should be like 90 players Where is Gumi?
I need, I need her to clutch it for me I need her, I need her to, I need her to like move on to day 4 for me and suffer Alright, where's me?
A, B, C, wait, where's D?
Oh my god, all the D's are almost dead Except for me!
Yay!
It's not metagaming because it's happening in-game We're just not allowed to metagame outside, like outside of the game
Guys, guys, oh my god, do you see that?
Guys, it's already getting spicy in the server People are already playing music in the lobby, can we please stop that?
Oh no, it's already getting spicy
Oh my god, they have to write it in Spanish too because they don't know They don't know, they just, it was a language barrier or not To be fair, the complaints of it was mostly in English, so I don't know if like the people, the Spanish players knew that that was not allowed Oh my god,
you got called out in two languages Oh my god, in front of everybody Oh my god, in front of everyone Holy shit, oh shoot, holy shit Oh my god, wait, Gumi's in the kitchen Gumi's gonna carry me, right?
She's gonna carry me, right?
Liars, there's no Gumi in here Oh, but there is a TV She's in the dining hall?
This is not, that's not a kitchen Guys, you guys need to know where, you guys need to know the difference between a kitchen and a dining hall
What?
Actually, oh my gosh What is the admin calling out about now?
Oh my god, the callouts are real The callouts are real I told you guys, they're enforcing the rules, like legit now Gumi!
Gumi, you didn't share one?
Get in the backpack, get in Yay Hey, I never told you this, but your skin, you put it on wrong I know, I can't peep, I know since day one, but I can't peep
It's okay, as long as the front works, that's all that matters Yeah,
for free Okie dokie
Gumi, did you see the harder enforcement of rules today?
Did you see that?
No swearing
Today will probably be the most RNG day, I think Gumi!
Gumi!
I'm so tired already
The thing is, I don't know if you get eliminated as a hider, as a prop hider How do the hunters get eliminated then?
I don't understand, why would the prop players want to call each other Why would the prop players call out other prop players?
Because how would the hunters die?
Like, I feel, that's just, that's just dumb Hey Gumi, do you understand the prop hunt thing on how it's getting I thought prop hunt would be like a team game, but did you see people were arguing about whether or not you can call, like, throw other prop players under the bus?
To get eliminated Um, I did see that Yeah, so I'm confused, I thought the prop hunt was a team based game No, I think it's a one for all A one, but then how would the hunters get eliminated?
I guess like If they don't hunt enough, if they don't get at least one person or something Yeah, but then like, prop players can get eliminated by like, you know, getting caught So like, how would That's so confusing So like, it's better, it's just better to be a hunter than a prop player Hello Yeah And Frost,
I have 28 Oh, for an important, oh, important announcement Server restarting?
Oh, they're restarting the server Guys, I thought, I, oh, I wish it was a team game Any music of any kind is not allowed in voice chat Nooooo Nooooo Why are you guys complaining about Minecraft players?
I'm just like Yeah, I'm just like, why does it matter?
I'm so confused Why would it matter if you can't play I wanna play music in voice chat Just play music in your own stream That doesn't make sense to me I'm sorry, I'm not, I don't understand Guys, I actually don't understand
Voice chat will be completely disabled by the server in, oh, in prop hunt Oh
Hello?
Hey So So Yeah?
I found out, okay, so they're turning off voice chat for the prop hunt thing so we don't grief each other Yeah I'm pretty sure it's like, hunters have to at least get one I'm pretty sure it's gonna be a really big house So like, it makes it even that hunters only have to get one and props have to survive I'm just like,
the transform run is just so confusing I'm just But I also don't like that we have to do tasks Yeah, you have to do tasks as a prop So it feels like it's better to be a hunter than a prop Cause it's easier to grab, like, hunt props Than it is to like,
be a prop And then you have to like, make sure you don't get caught while doing tasks Cause I feel like props get eliminated so fast because of it Yeah, I agree Yeah, that's why I was like, so confused It would've been better if it was just a team game And then like,
all the props are like, if the hunters win and get everybody All the props would win on one side Cause then it's more RNG And like, people can actually work together Yeah, it's kinda like, you're trying to think of like, prop hunt rules Yeah Yeah Cause I feel like it's hard to eliminate...
Cause it's just better to be RNG'd as a hunter Than it is to be RNG'd as a prop Cause like, what if you just don't do anything What if you just do one task and then like...
Or like, what if all the prop players successfully do all the tasks And not like...
It's just confusing!
Are you in the lobby now?
Um, I'm launching Yeah, yeah, cause, you know, you see the new forum They're like, nobody is allowed to use third party I was like, people were using Discord?
Dude, I thought that shit wasn't allowed Like, from day one Yeah, and then I'm like, did they get disqualified?
Or are they still in the game?
I'm like, that's pretty unfair They're using Discord groups I have to deal with 100 people spamming my lobby And they get to be in a Discord group?
Yeah, what's it called?
I found out that in-game...
I forgot that in-game voice Yeah, it has a group chat Yeah, I disabled it Yeah, I asked a question about it They're like, no, not allowed Yeah, so for chat, for those who don't know This is actually not allowed, the group voice chat Even though it's in the game It's not allowed Because they want to be fair They want everybody to have...
To use voice proximity Alright, I'm launching now Alright, I'll see you in-game Okay, bye bye Bye bye Guys, I'm pretty sure Guys If we make it to the second game If I get propped, it's over
If I get propped, it's so over
Guys, they actually have to disable the voice chat So it's emotes mode only In the transform In the prop hut No, we have to do tasks Dude, if we're propped We have to do tasks So we can't stay propped forever We have to move around And do stuff And that's what I'm saying If we get propped The RNG is so bad Because the hunter just have to camp I guess if they don't know the tasks They can't camp it But it feels like it's easier To be a hunter Yeah!
The hunter advantage
It's so...
Oh my god, it's so big 30 people will be eliminated And transported to prop hut 2 Because I'm like thinking I honestly thought it was supposed to be a team game That's like legit That's what I thought I was like, oh my gosh, it's like a team game Because like Because like Whoever,
whichever side wins They get to move on But no, it's not a team game It's not It's not a team game It's a one for all
It's a one for all Every Every hunter Every hunter And prop for themselves Chat Alright Let's see They're completely disabling voice chat So other props Other props can't throw Other props can't throw each other out To get eliminated fast That just makes me wonder I guess like props That have the least completed task Get eliminated But then like what if there's like
I'm just like thinking like I'm just thinking like what if we have this like what if we have more more members?
Like I guess we'll have to do tiebreakers Because what if like there's hunters that got like zero kills And there's props that done zero tasks but like Zero tasks, but there's like more How do you eliminate all the gardens look the same in mine eyes?
Yeah, I brought us in a wrong side.
Oh my god Is there a third one there she's running us around
And give me a zero Yeah
Average day Registered in the state of YouTube.
Oh Wait, I don't care
Hey, I actually don't care about the Easter
I Still find Easter eggs There's no there's no that's a lie
Remember you lied before Yeah, who needs eggs I need to make a wait.
Is there another there's another at it's another announcement.
Oh My god, look at the crowd for the Easter egg.
It's like when you dangle keys in front of a baby, but you dangle
Wait, wait, oh Okay It's like dangling He's in front of a child.
We're dangling Easter eggs in front of like the minecraft players.
So like To like pad the time oh
My god, where's your hat?
My god, it looks like you shaved the top of your head What happened to your skin
Doesn't look right doesn't look right at all Well, where'd she go?
Oh my god, she died.
Oh my god.
She disappeared Well one less play one less player to worry about
I'm joking guys.
I'm joking She carried me all the way to gate A3 There goes your cake exactly guys guys, I'm joking I need her to carry me it did wait no No, she's gone There's a high chance.
I'll get eliminated on the first game and if I get eliminated in the first game, I Don't have to do day four
I Can I can sleep in instead of waking up at 11 30 a.m.
I can wake up at 2 p.m Tomorrow I can I can wake up at 2 p.m.
Guys.
Yeah, I don't have to sleep early I can I can just I Can just not not stream
Tokyo's losing it all I'm saying guys with Gumi eliminated There is a higher chance that I too will be Snap out of it.
I don't have to stay awake at- I'm holding everybody hostage, even my own.
I'm holding myself hostage.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's the new- There's a new announcement?
What is it?
Alright.
Alright, what is the new- Guys, seriously, stop playing music over a mic!
Are people still doing it?
Bro, oh my god.
Oh my god.
People are admin mad.
Admin's actually mad.
They're like, alright, we're actually gonna remove people now.
You keep playing music?
Oh my god, guys.
I'm going to start snitching.
Oh my god, it's time.
It's time to start my jokey arc and start snitching.
Quit playing music and be free.
No, no.
If I can, like, catch people.
If I can catch people playing music, one less person to worry about.
No negativity, remember?
It's not negativity.
I'm looking at the competitive integrity of this game.
Oh my god, you're right.
If I play- That's actually messed up.
Whoever- That's like a brilliant plan.
Like, oh my god, a villain came up with this perfect plan.
That's when you know I'm not a villain.
It's the fact that I'm not an actual villain because even I wouldn't have come up with that.
But some of my chat was like, quick, play music over a group of people and call somebody out.
That's so evil.
That's actually so goddamn evil.
Oh my god.
You, sir, are a very evil person.
That's so- Guys, the Among Us part of this game ended, chat.
Oh my god, we're 30 minutes late because the server is messed up at the moment.
Alright, let's see.
What was the info?
Ooh, okay.
Interesting.
Guys,
we got insider info.
I'm gonna snitch them out for it.
You heard the secrets too?
Yeah.
We're being spied on, June.
Is the TV up there?
No, there is a TV up there, though, if you need to get that.
Oh, I got that one.
I got three secret guys.
Oh, you're in one that I haven't found.
What are you gonna do?
Uninstall the info from my brain?
Oh, thank god!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna snitch them.
I'm gonna snitch them out to the admins.
One of your admins gave the other player insider info, so she was metagaming!
She was metagaming!
Rule number 33!
I don't know where any more are.
Oh my god!
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi, I heard insider info from somebody that's apparently friends with the admin.
They were telling one player that the doll is gonna get faster and faster each round.
The evil doll.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like hide-and-seek tag.
Like musical chairs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, musical chairs with hide-and-seek.
So like, if you are unlucky and you get a bad doll, you have to start hiding.
Yeah, you know, I find it funny, Anne, how we were saying we want to search everywhere but the black corner, and that's exactly where it was.
Does it really matter, though?
Wait, I'm at 102.
Woah!
They did also, I know they did turn down the default render distance as well.
I turned it back up, though, because I just wasn't rendering the whole lobby.
Yeah, I turned down the render distance just because I didn't need that much.
I might turn it back down, to be honest.
I'm at like 8.
I'm gonna see if people are still complaining about the music.
I don't think it matters if the frames are low.
Yeah, but we're not talking during the game, we're just talking while we wait for the event to start.
I'm around like 2,000 render distance right now.
Yeah, I did the same thing, I feel like they're talking about us.
So how's the rest week?
Well, I've been in a server with 100 plus people for like three days straight.
Oh my god, guys, look, goodnight right there!
My social media is gone.
My social battery is not okay at the moment.
It's not okay.
Sounds like the opposite of resting.
Oh my god, 10 seconds.
10 seconds, guys.
Oh my god, I cannot wait.
I cannot wait to be the first 10 out.
I cannot wait, guys!
Illuminated guy!
Oh wait.
All on red!
I need to take my meds too.
I should take my meds too.
The voices, they're getting louder!
I wonder, are they gonna TPS based off of what color we're standing on?
Yeah, yeah, sure.
Oh, I have an idea.
If we both...
If we both pick the same doll, the doll will only kill one of us.
That sounds like the most...
Worst idea you've ever come up with.
But like, that's why it's a 50-50.
No, it sounds like you're a dumb...
You can't swear in profanity!
Rule 12!
What were you gonna say?
Dumb what?
Just dumb, you're just dumb.
I feel like there was a second word there.
Dumb bear, dumb bear, dumb bear, dumb bear.
All I'm saying is that the doll will only pick one of us.
I think it's a good plan, I don't understand.
You're the same person who doesn't know how to read.
Yeah, but that doesn't require reading, it's just probability.
It's just probability.
It's probability, it's math.
We're trying to deal with math, right?
We're next to the...
Wait, the Spanish players know what they're doing.
Oh my god, it's like roulette!
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so scary.
This is literally RNG.
Oh, I hate this, my stress is already going up.
My stress is already going up, I hate this.
I'm already anxious.
I'm gonna report this to Catherine.
What?
There are only five dolls of this type left?
Bro, what?
Wait, then everybody could like...
Wait, then how do you live?
You just run around in a circle?
Circle?
Bro, what the heck?
That's so scary!
That's gonna be me.
What?
Wait.
Can they like...
Can they like open the place?
Oh!
Wait, that's dumb!
Wait, that's... what if like...
Oh, that's so disgusting.
I'm already stressed out listening to this.
What?
Let's gotcha!
I'm gonna use all of them so no one can hide.
That's so true.
That's actually so scary.
Oh my gosh, that's actually so scary.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's only if you choose the doll that's...
I'm listening to other people's strats.
I'm listening to other people's strats right now.
Yes!
The fridge is gonna save us!
Yeah.
So we're gonna put the same square together?
Really?
Use the hiding spots later.
Oh, okay.
But what if like...
But if we use up all the hiding spaces, then nobody can get it.
Yeah, but that means you also can't get it, idiot.
Yeah, but the probability wise.
Yeah, I don't think it matters where you stay.
I feel like...
I don't know.
Can we all agree not to use the hiding cluster later in the game?
Let's use the hiding cluster.
Is everybody in the room?
Why would it be...
No, I shouldn't stick with the pros because the pros are faster runners.
Why don't you play DbD and just break their ankles, man?
All I'm saying, guys, you know what that doesn't...
Guys, if I always stick with the pros, if we get RNG into a core stall, all of them are better players than me and they would kill me first.
They're faster runners.
Oh, wow, holy frick.
Yeah, that's why I'm scared.
Do you want to be in the big room?
So just spread out.
What happens if not surviving?
My container desk is messing me up, guys.
Yeah, I think everybody goes there.
I can survive if it's yours.
Those voices are so strong!
I can't.
I survived.
I'm surprised I survived as long as I could.
I'm surprised I survived this long.
It was just... it was a lot.
It was a lot.
Alright, if I stick with... I think I'm gonna stick with the crowd, then.
The more people... I guess the more people there are in that space...
The...
What was everybody voting for?
If there's a huge amount of people together...
Then, like, probability-wise, maybe?
The stress!
We all suffer the same fate together.
Oh, God.
I'm actually anxious.
I don't know why.
I don't know why I'm so anxious.
No!
There are only one doll?!
That's messed up.
That's actually messed up, guys.
That's so messed up.
I'm so...
How did... How did I...
Oh, my.
It's... Oh, Chris.
It's me.
It always happens.
To Doki!
The Doki experience.
Right here.
The Doki experience right now.
This is the Doki experience.
Oh, wait.
Everybody's running.
Why is everybody running right now?
Five minutes of this...
FIVE MINUTES OF THIS?!
If I stand in the middle...
Oh, no.
A lot of people are running away.
So that, like, makes me really nervous.
Like, why are people running away?
I want to stay near the crowd.
Audio for you.
I'm running.
Why are you running?
Because it's coming.
Intel.
I didn't know if you were just getting your steps in.
Oh, my God.
Yay, free Intel!
The herd mentality!
I love following the herd!
Are you guys trolling?
FOLLOW THE HERD!
What does it mean if you're even safe?
M, what does Sigma mean?
Follow the herd.
Mob is strong to get in.
I like crowds, personally.
Mob is strong to get in there.
Guys, stop laughing.
Two minutes.
Two minutes for you.
Just hold.
Hold.
Holy, this is abnormal.
I'm lying.
Serpio is abnormal.
Mob is strong to get in.
No, don't do it!
No!
Oh, my God.
No, that was aura, bro.
Bro, that was aura.
Plus 1,000 aura.
Is it coming?
Kill someone, bro.
Just kill someone.
Just kill my mate.
This doll got one-tapped, man.
Is it coming?
I'm worried at the end.
All 40 of us in here are gonna be the ones to get out.
If no one dies, there's gonna be 10 rounds until someone dies.
Like, 15 minutes.
Yeah, we all win.
They have to split the money.
They give us each $70,000.
Can we vote someone to be like $70,000?
Not it.
Did not mean.
Okay, fine.
We'll sacrifice Andre.
This has to be the longest 2 minutes.
Yo, I'll sacrifice for 40 Gs.
What?
This sucks.
Sorry.
I'm actually losing it.
It's so...
I'm stuck in purgatory!
This is...
Ah!
Freaking purgatory!
I think it was the color that had the most people.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
I mean, it's the color that has the most votes.
It's gonna increase its speed.
The doll.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, I'm nervous.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
How is there only one person and then we're free?
That's so mean!
Polo!
Marco!
Guys, always go together to the same color, okay?
If you are with a...
It's coming!
Yeah, he's going!
He's going!
Fuck the pickle.
Polo!
Just stand in the back.
Behind us!
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Everybody run!
I was here earlier.
I don't know if he's still chilling.
Let's run into it!
Oh my god!
It hit me!
I saw somebody got hit!
What?
They didn't get one?
How do I come back to the room?
I got hit twice by it.
Oh my god!
My health restored!
That's so stressful!
That was so stressful!
Where is the entrance?
TPS!
Oh, it's here.
Oh, we're back.
Okay.
Do we go out on the same line?
Purple!
Blue!
It's okay.
There's a crowd.
It's gonna be me, right?
It's gonna be me.
I'm okay!
Nice!
Wait, all of us have chosen safe?
Grey!
Wait, what?
We already chose this!
Grey is bad!
It's gonna be me!
I mean, at least there's no RNG on what we choose.
Everybody gets a prize.
There's a huge crowd here.
Okay.
I'm confused.
What?
No!
That's me, right?
Okay, bye-bye!
That's me!
This thing is fast.
Is that all of us?
Wait, is it like majority?
I'm so confused.
It's for everybody!
I'm dead!
I hear him!
I'd rather stay with the group.
We got this.
Oh, there's a group there.
Nice.
Oh!
Coming!
He's coming!
This doll is gonna have a different ability than the last one.
So we don't know how...
He's gonna have Aura.
This doll has kill Aura.
He's coming or not?
Is she coming?
Don't attract her!
So you might not be able to outrun her.
I'm sure you can kill her.
Oh my god!
He's coming!
I got you.
Oh!
He's got somebody!
I give it!
Oh my god!
Another round!
At least we won't have to be here for 15 minutes.
We played!
We eliminated!
The save dolls are just pointless.
This is so stressful.
Yeah, it's bad.
Oh man.
Gray's bad.
This part doesn't matter.
And the save dolls don't matter.
Do not go back to the middle.
I was getting nailed.
I was getting scared.
I was alone.
Purple!
We're back.
Just fucking run!
Just run!
Let's keep running.
I can't go to the intersection.
Follow Pumi.
Just follow Pumi.
Who's the hero?
I don't like this.
Just keep swimming.
I don't like that.
Are you running or what?
Are you running?
No, no, we're fine.
It's a terrible spot.
It's actually not terrible.
No, it's the best spot.
Guys, I'm scared.
I don't want to die.
Run for the doll!
Purple!
I'm serious!
The cry of help, though.
The cry of help.
I'm serious!
There are multiple.
Oh my god.
There were two before.
Hold the corner!
The cry of help.
Don't chase him!
Cunning!
Fear!
What is going on?
Absolute fear and mayhem.
That's what.
That's what's going on.
What is going on?
This is like the Stanford Prison Experiment.
Don't try to play it.
I swear.
That researchers are going to study this.
I'm going with this game.
Oh no.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I peaced away from the group.
I'm so scared.
No.
Oh my god.
There are multiple.
We are trapped.
Oh my god.
We got so lucky.
What is the point of the safe dolls?
I still don't understand the game.
Everybody has to run.
Yeah.
There is no point in having a safe doll.
If people are going to die, you got this.
Safe doll delays the game.
And I feel like...
Here we go again.
It doesn't matter.
It's majority.
It's always majority.
That's the thing.
It doesn't matter, guys.
It's there that majority picks.
Everybody still has to run.
So it doesn't matter if you pick a safe doll.
If the majority picks a bad doll, it's over.
I'll watch this corner too.
Keep a big group over there.
I'll stay here.
No matter what, somebody has to die.
Andres, I hope you know we're sacrificing you for us.
No, no, no.
Guys, eight more to go.
We have eight more to go.
I'm good.
I'm fine.
Guys, there's nothing here.
Can we peek further if it's over?
No!
There's like eight more dolls to go.
They're coming.
We're coming.
I hope it means the dolls are fast.
They kill people faster.
Because each round is faster.
I'm so scared.
I don't know why they're trying to find things.
Oh, we're so good.
I don't know.
Hi.
Apparently the suits are not very safe.
They're running on the left.
They'll camp you.
They'll camp you?
Then there's no point in having hiding spots.
Okay, you know what?
Run, run, run, run, run.
They're beaches.
Okay, okay, okay.
My heart.
My poor heart.
I don't know where it went.
We're chilling, guys.
We're locked in.
It looks like we're okay.
Play the corner.
Hold the corner.
How many hearts?
It does half a heart.
You can get hit four times.
Yeah, me too.
Take one from the team.
I'm chilling.
My therapy.
Sam, Sam.
Are you running?
Are you safe?
There's two dolls that direction, but they turned left.
There's two dolls that direction.
I think we're good over here right now.
Are they faster than you running?
You can outrun them right now.
The dolls will find you.
Leave the group.
I left the group and I got fucking tapped.
Okay, okay, okay.
Together, always.
Siempre juntos.
Always together.
Sacrifice Doki.
Wait, why me?
I didn't do anything.
I'm just a baby.
Doki's cool.
Music's getting very loud.
I don't have any music.
Doki alone.
Is that why there's music?
Is anybody being hunted right now?
Negative behavior.
No, baby, we see you.
No pee-pee.
Pee-pee in pants.
Hey, hey, hey.
Go, go, go, go.
Nothing to be afraid of.
We're not cheating.
I do not.
I cannot shoot anymore.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Do not.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Oh, I messed up the series.
I messed up the series.
I'm not in the group.
Everybody conga.
Come and do the conga.
Spam, spam, spam, spam.
Guys, how do we get intel if everybody's getting it?
Okay, this is not intel.
This is just a school trip that you can't get off of.
You can't get out.
This is worse.
It's like a mandatory school trip.
Karma.
I sure hope the next one is a safe dog.
I sure hope it's a safe dog.
That's what you get.
Karma.
He actually got karma.
Yes, he got it.
I'm going to throw up.
I hate this.
He actually got karma.
That's so funny.
I hate this.
This is it.
I'm after A.
It doesn't matter anyway, guys.
No, what am I saying?
It doesn't matter.
It's majority.
I feel like when people pick safe dogs, they should be safe.
I feel like if you pick safe dog, you should automatically be safe.
Papo, you went alone last time.
You should not be forced to do this.
We should not be forced.
If you have a safe dog, you shouldn't be forced to do this again.
People are coming.
I feel like he might be revived.
Is he coming?
This is the illusion of choice.
I can't take this.
We all lose.
I feel like he is camping the dog.
It's a guy that wanted to be my wife.
Six more to go.
It's time for God lost his male wife.
It doesn't matter where we are.
They randomly put us.
They randomly group us out.
It doesn't matter where we are.
It doesn't matter where you get grouped up into.
It's random.
It was invisible.
It was invisible, chief.
I swear, it was actually not there.
I'm next to this door.
It doesn't matter.
We all get caught.
Not even on that, but we all get caught.
No, that doesn't exist.
We know the route.
We know the route, guys.
I'm in the middle.
Because I don't contribute.
I'm a leech.
I'm just here to leech.
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm safe, no worries.
Dukie rat tactics.
We're going for the drone.
Of course.
They're running, they're running.
They're coming to me.
Are they around here?
I don't know.
Run, run.
They're running.
We're running for nothing, bro.
I think we're running for nothing.
Wait, wait, wait.
Stop it, stop it, stop it.
Stop it, guys.
Stop it, stop it.
Stop it.
Hold the corner.
Corner, corner, corner.
We're in such a grief, bro.
Do you guys see anything?
Yeah.
Dukie.
Dukie, Dukie...
It's safe, it's safe, it's safe.
There's my mother.
The kid in the supermarket...
I can't stay...
There's a kid in the supermarket...
Where's my mom?
Get up, get up, get up.
Sam's balls are on the ground, dude.
Bro, I thought game day 2 was bad.
I don't know, this is worse.
This is actually much worse than day 2.
This is worse.
And I have to listen to the voices.
I need an adult.
I need an adult, guys.
The voices.
The audio is louder.
They're running, they're running.
They're running, they're running, they're running.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
This could be a tie.
Watch out for being pinched.
Watch in front of you.
Following Sam, following Sam.
Everyone go the same way.
Don't split, don't split, don't split.
Stay in a group.
Don't split, guys, don't split.
Behind you, behind you, behind you.
Let's go to the center, let's go to the center.
I am Cormie.
Who is Cormie?
It says Cormie.
Cormie.
I am Cormie, guys.
He was actually Cormie!
It was very close.
It's okay, it's okay.
I am Cormie.
Okay, in the corner, corner, corner.
In the center, in the center.
I apologize a million times.
I'm sorry, Miss Jackson.
Twitch Sims is back!
Enough,
enough, enough.
Potras!
Let's troll...
Lime, lime, lime, lime, lime!
Both lime, both lime, both lime.
Both lime, lime, lime.
Both lime, lime, lime, lime.
Quindo, quiet, quiet.
Listen to me, listen to me.
I'm so...
Lime, lime, lime, lime.
Green is life, green is life.
Green and then black.
Green, what's your problem?
What does green do?
What's green's power?
Each doll has a different ability.
These dolls are faster, these dolls are faster.
No, no, no, no.
Yay.
I'm skeptical, I'm skeptical, I'm skeptical.
I don't know what that even means for us.
It's not good because it doesn't matter if we're safe!
It's even doesn't matter where!
It doesn't matter!
We're not actually safe!
I'm so scared!
What's the point?
10 people have to die anyways, right?
I'm just making this round longer!
Yeah, regenerate.
Oh, please!
We already had three dolls left!
Okay, we obviously know what a good doll looks like.
Light blue, light blue, light blue.
Light blue, light blue, light blue, light blue.
No, no, she's bad, she's bad, she's bad.
Oh, this bet is going to shake.
I've been here before, my sanity drops.
Oh, this is supposed to be the less stressful one, too!
This is supposed to be the less stressful one.
What's the point of this?
Good question!
What is the point of the safe doll?
Very good question!
Nobody knows!
Nobody knows what's the point of the safe doll.
Stay in the safe zone.
Oh, they can shoot you?
Stay here, stay here.
We've been chilling here, we've been chilling.
We've been chilling, we've been chilling.
Oh, my God!
I like how the strategists follow the Spanish players.
They know what they're doing.
They know exactly what they're doing.
Oh, my God.
$70,000 for that in America?
That's a lot of money converted for them.
There!
That's when you know they really want to win, guys.
It's not going to lie.
$70,000, it's like you're set.
There's definitely two of these ones.
These guys are running here, they're running right now.
They're running, they're running.
Me too, because it's 100k Canadian.
Me too!
Me too, because it's like 100k Canadian.
I'm behind every middle, I'm behind every middle.
I don't feel safe, bro!
That's so loud!
There was like explosions.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
He did it!
Yes!
What?
Hold your breath!
I was
1HP!
I was 1HP!
Come here, I was 1HP!
Hey!
I was 1HP!
I would've been out!
Are you like... are you like dissociated from all the noise?
Gumi is so done.
Honestly, same.
It's magenta!
Five more.
Five more!
I'll be okay if I get a win here.
I actually... I can.
I can.
I'm so tired.
I'm so goddamn tired, guys.
Is there one behind us?
I haven't seen him.
That was fast!
That was so fast!
That was so fast.
Oh my god, you're a lot faster now.
Oh my god, we're dying.
Well, now the superior red man to the left has gotten rid of the competition.
Guys, guys, if he's gonna hit you, just hit the spots.
The hidden spots.
If he's gonna hit you, just thug it out.
Just ignore him.
Don't, don't, don't.
Hit the thug shake.
Thug shake.
Shake?
I'm gonna shake you, Gumi.
I got that one.
You're happy in your nightclub, you're head's so sunny.
If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
If you're happy and you know it, everyone's jealous.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
During my pride, how dare you?
During my pride?
This is a social experiment.
This is a Stanford Prison experiment.
I refuse to believe this is a tournament anymore.
This is a psychology experiment.
On the declining mental capacity of a typical extremer.
I refuse to believe...
He's coming for us.
But they're all faster than me.
Oh, I'm so upset.
I'm so nervous.
These guys are all good Minecraft players.
He's so loud.
They're all better players than me.
No, I'm so nervous.
They're all so much better players than me.
I'm so upset.
Run, run, run.
No, get out.
Don't let them get out.
No, nothing, nothing, nothing, nothing.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
They're all faster than me.
Help.
Nothing, nothing, nothing.
He's here, he's here.
He's still there, he's still there.
No, I messed up the stairs, I messed up the stairs, guys, I messed up the stairs.
No, not safe, not safe, not safe.
He's right there.
Axe or no?
He's still behind, he's still behind, he's still behind.
He's still right behind.
I don't like him.
You live with my dream, stay with me.
Relocate my fantasy.
I stay reality.
You live with my dream, stay with me.
See you in this fucking galaxy.
Oh, what the fuck?
Run, run, run, run, run.
It's on us, it's on us, it's on us, it's on us.
It's right there, it's right there, it's right there.
I'm so scared, I'm so scared, I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh please, just kill somebody.
This mental torture.
Oh my god, this mental torture.
Just give us money for this, I don't care.
We deserve money for doing this.
The sick entertainment for viewers.
We deserve money for this.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
This is so sad.
We deserve to be rewarded by Twitch for this.
Not you guys, not you guys.
Twitch, Twitch, Twitch, Twitch.
Twitch, Twitch, Twitch.
We deserve $70,000.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god.
Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
We can't mute guys, we have to listen to Noah and we have to run.
That's the worst part.
We have to run.
I'll try and turn it down again.
Dude, this game is lasting way too much.
How many people need to die?
I don't know.
Three?
Three more.
Goodbye,
this is it.
I can feel it, this has to be it, this has to be it.
Please, please just kill me.
Just take me out.
Please, just like instantly run at me.
I don't care.
Just instantly run at me.
Is it coming?
Don't stop, don't stop, don't stop.
Don't stop.
Believe in me.
Hold on to my feelings.
You were so close.
It was literally right here.
Was it right here?
Yeah, this one is really bad.
We should stop this one.
We should just stop taking this one.
I think we have to go for every single one of them now.
The other guy, Axel, is my friend.
Why are you guys not coming to me?
No, leave me alone.
Leave me alone, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Yeah, brown neck.
Leave, leave.
Don't come near me.
Yeah, I don't know.
Alright, this is where I die.
Just run at me.
Stab me, that's all I want.
Just stab me.
Put me out of my misery.
I'm being hunted.
Is he coming?
Yes.
No.
Is it a question mark?
I don't think any of them followed.
I saw it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One followed once.
Oh my god, I thought it was going to be hunting me.
I thought it was it.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
We shouldn't run, we shouldn't run.
We should stay in the corner, guys.
Is it behind us?
I don't know, but it's somewhere.
It's not behind us.
Why would we move from a place that's...
Sylvie, Sylvie, come, come, come.
Sylvie, come, come, come.
Sylvie, my friend, right in the corner.
I don't trust that spot, guys.
Watch that side, I'm going to watch that side.
I mean, I got it.
It's hunting you from over here, so...
This is so sad.
I got one earlier, that's why I wanted to go...
The groups are shrinking, man.
Oh, there's a group coming over here.
Oh, there's a group coming.
Question, question, question.
He's running from the other end.
Oh yeah, it's right here, it's right here.
It's right in front of me, it's right in front of me.
There's one here as well, there's one here as well.
They turned around, they turned around.
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh.
Stay near the other crab, stay near the other crab, stay near the other crab.
Remember guys, just don't die and everything will be fine.
Wolfie, just stay back there, you're good.
Oh, he is behind us, wow.
He hit my butt.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh no, this is it, this is it guys, this is it.
I'm the slowest.
I don't know the tech, I don't know the tech.
Goodbye.
Goodbye guys.
I don't know the running tech.
It is right behind us, it is right behind us.
I don't know.
I don't know the running tech, this is it.
Oh, got me one too.
Gooby, gooby, run.
We had a good run.
We had such a good run, everybody.
We had such a good run, everyone.
We had an insane run, everybody, but this is it.
This is it.
You got me there.
No, no.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, nevermind, it's still there.
Throw in fireballs, throw in fireballs.
Oh my god.
I just want somebody to turn around and just take it.
This is not even like hide anymore, it's just run.
It's not even hide and seek.
It's like a marathon run.
We're just doing a marathon right now.
Turn, turn, turn, turn, turn.
Convergence.
Turn, turn, turn, turn, turn, turn.
Turn around, turn around, turn around, turn around.
Oh my god.
It's a goddamn marathon.
Turn around, turn around.
I'm scared.
Every now and then I fall apart.
And I cannot be alive.
It just killed like three people, honestly.
This is not good.
We gotta converge with those guys.
I screwed up.
Oh, here it is.
The sacrifice.
Goodbye, funny guy 312.
This is it.
It would be so poetic that I got eliminated last person.
As the last person, I get eliminated right away.
It'd be so poetic though.
Oh my god.
After going through the entire round, the stressful day, I am the last person to be out.
It would be so poetic.
Guys, green is not gonna happen.
Green is not gonna happen.
I'm gonna be honest.
Why does it have to be green?
Why does it have to be safe?
Why?
I don't care.
I'm just not there.
No matter what, I'm just not there.
No matter what happens, I just don't wanna be there.
Flex.
This is the good one.
And that's it?
It's over?
No, and then we go for the bad one.
It doesn't make sense how good it is.
Yeah.
It's a challenge.
This is not a challenge.
Flex, did you notice the color?
The color you chose.
Oh my god.
Don't be safe.
Why does he keep screaming?
Who is this?
Call the streamer out right now.
And I will specifically meet that person in voice chat if I live.
Is it?
Oh my god.
Okay, I have power.
Okay, well, there's just one dog left.
Okay.
What's the point of safe dogs, bro?
Where is he?
Oh wait, I got the wrong one.
Whoops, sorry.
It's meaningless.
We're all meant to die anyway.
Red guys don't die.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, thank you for the tier one.
I'm going through hell right now.
This is it.
Goodbye.
Everybody, it was a good run.
It was a good run, everyone.
I had a...
It was a good run.
I had a great time being here with everybody.
It was such a good run that like...
We had such a good run.
It was such a good run and this is where we...
This is where we call it.
Guys, if it says that it's targeting you, you have to jump inside one of those hiding places.
If you don't do it, it's going to kill you.
I was targeted last time.
That's insane.
GG!
No way!
He lost.
He died.
No...
I mean, are we the last like six from our room, guys?
Oh my god!
Wait, is that how it works?
What the hell?
I think so.
I think we all have like a set spawn room in like a restaurant.
It'll just be a couple...
This is the pain that never ends.
I think this one was the worst one.
One more game.
30 people.
30 people are going to get eliminated in the next one.
It's the prop hunt game.
The...
Wait, you all got eliminated?
Oh my god!
Too fair.
I was surprised he lived this long.
Oh my god!
I was just so stressed.
Oh my god.
I need to be in a corner.
I need to...
Wait.
Okay, that's cool.
Give me a sec, guys.
Oh my god.
Let me turn down the...
Wait, voice chat would be...
Okay, give me a sec.
I actually need to reset myself.
Oh my god.
I feel like they should have play tested that game.
Devlin, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so sorry for the voices, guys.
I couldn't take my meds, guys.
We needed intel.
I'm so...
I'm so sorry for the screaming earlier.
Bro, I'm so tired.
That one game exhausted me.
Oh my god.
That one fucking game actually exhausted me.
I actually had to mute somebody.
I was like, no, bro.
If this is a Stanford prison experiment, bro, I'm fucking...
Let me out.
Let me out of that prison.
The voices were so strong.
Oh my god.
All that for 10 people to be eliminated.
That's the worst part.
Only 10 people were eliminated.
At least the experiment subjects got paid.
Bro, I should get paid.
I should get paid for like the mental toll that took out of me.
It was good content.
Yeah, the next game is 30.
Bro, those puppets should have killed 20 people.
I don't understand.
They should have gotten a goddamn double kill.
Instead, they put us through hell.
They put us through hell for this sick entertainment.
Bro, it's just a game.
Oh my god.
It might be just a game.
I felt like I just aged another 50 years playing this game.
Nobody gets paid until day 5.
The content of winning.
I was actually going crazy.
I was going goddamn crazy.
I thought I was gonna turn into Joker.
I thought I was gonna turn into Joker right there.
Oh my god.
Oh, but it's over.
Day 10.
Game 2.
Prop hunt.
I'm gonna die so fast as a prop, guys.
Knowing my luck, I'm gonna get prop.
I'm gonna get like instant fucking ganked by a hunter.
Jokeybird is coming back.
I had to mute.
I can't.
I can't listen to the voices anymore.
Guys.
Are they looking at a funeral for their friend?
Oh, they are.
Okay.
We're gonna have a vlog.
I'm gonna let you know what's inside.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay, I don't think they're friends.
Guys, I don't think that was a friend, guys.
That was definitely not a poor friend.
Hello.
I'm here.
Yeah.
I made it.
I was hunted.
It's okay.
You didn't die.
All my other friends died.
This is hell, Gumi.
That last game was hell.
I don't know if you're gonna like the next game anymore.
I think the next game is harder.
Yeah.
Gumi was a good run, Gumi.
Get to day 4 for me, Gumi.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Gumi.
Live on for me.
Live on.
If you're a hunter and I'm a prop, I'll give you that one point, Gumi.
I don't know how to find you.
You'll know it's me.
You go into a room and you see a prop moving.
That's me.
You take that one point.
You take that one point and take it over the day 4, Gumi.
I don't know how it's gonna be like.
It's basically a... It's like a...
One for all.
That's what you said.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It can't be team.
Abe died because his game crashed.
Wait, really?
That's why he died?
You know what's funny?
Abe was like, we should sacrifice Doki to the monster.
And then he died like 10 seconds later.
I'll be honest, I was so ready to sacrifice any random that I saw.
I was like, nothing's chasing us.
Bro, I just wanted it to be over.
That shit was so stressful.
Did you F5?
No, I didn't.
I just followed the crowd.
The safe zones didn't matter.
I didn't understand the safe zones.
It didn't matter.
It was just until we got rid of all the dolls.
The safe zones actually did nothing.
Yeah, it did nothing.
It just prolonged the game.
Yeah, and we had to choose all the dolls anyway, so what's the point?
Yeah, and then there's always majority.
Majority wins.
So it doesn't matter what we choose.
Illusion, I chose Illusion.
Yeah, and then one guy was screaming at the top of his... I muted that guy.
Who is it?
Tell me who is it.
Oh, you're going to mute him too?
Yeah, it's the sap guy.
I know who you're talking about.
Yeah, I muted him.
I was like, chat, tell me who it is.
I can't.
I cannot hear him yell at everybody anymore.
Oh no, yeah, I kept muting until you got mid-round just to hear if someone's coming or not.
Yeah, I kept it on the entire time because I was so scared.
I was so scared that I was going to die.
No, I was kind of getting pissed off.
Oh no, I was just crying.
I feel like loud does not equal funny, so I was just getting...
Yeah, it was just not funny.
Like, unless you say something funny, but they weren't saying anything funny.
It's the person I lied to on day one.
I feel bad.
Rest in peace.
I don't.
I learned that from the Spanish people.
I unmuted and they were spitting at somebody's grave.
Yeah, I was like, oh look, they're paying respect to their dead friend.
And then I muted and it was just a group of people like spitting on his grave.
I was like, oh, I don't think that's a friend.
Yeah, I'm watering the grass a little bit.
A VTuber lived longer than you.
Oh shit, we're on the main channel.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry, Eva.
Okay, are we off yet?
She's watering the flowers, man.
We're watering the flowers.
Who's next?
Okay, that's not me, guys.
That's not me.
They heard all of it, Gooby.
We're just paying respect by helping make sure the flowers... yeah.
See, Mendo has no flowers.
Yeah, because nobody paid respect to him.
We're making sure that they're hydrated.
Oh, this one I can't spit on.
I'm going to throw it back on the floor.
Okay, me too.
I don't know who they are, but I will too.
We're going to say our goodbyes to Red Velvet.
I didn't mean to say goodbye to Gooby.
I meant to say goodbye to Red Velvet.
No, no, no, no, no.
On Pride Month?
I don't remember the rest.
I don't know who this person is, but 07.
Is this the guy that you were talking about?
You don't like this guy?
No, this guy didn't even follow me back on Twitter.
Damn!
Who is this guy?
Wait, did he get out in this last game?
No, yesterday.
I was going to say, we had a run from the beast, but surely you'd think Sonic would be fast.
Clearly not.
No, they lost in the task one.
The puzzle, quote-unquote.
Damn, so he might be fast with his feet, but he's not fast with his brain.
Oh my god, look, it's me!
I see you!
And dead bodies to the left and right of you.
Yeah, all my friends are freaking dead.
No, no, there's still Bear.
Bear is still alive.
Mr. Bear.
Yeah, Wall-E is still alive.
Where's your grave, Doki?
Mine's all the way back here.
Right at the beginning?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it alphabetical?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, so I get the front.
Shay, wanna hear something funny?
Yeah.
Doki hard muted self now.
That's funny.
I think it's so funny.
I mean, I don't blame you.
He was screaming, I was like, I clearly can't focus.
During the last game?
Yeah.
Oh, you muted him during the last game?
No, no, yeah, during the last game I muted him.
I was like, chat, who is this person that keeps yelling?
And everybody just said, that guy.
So, that might have been my fault, because I had a strategy, and he was like right next to me.
And I knew people would listen to him, because he just screams.
Hold on, rules are up.
Yeah?
What?
Okay.
Rules are up.
Oh, okay.
Eight people get selected.
Oh, so you have to like, survive, and you get points, and you have to complete tasks, and you get points.
Activate a locked door.
Oh my, what are these?
Oh, you respawn if you're a hunter as a prop.
Bro, what the heck, this rules is like, an essay.
I'll show a video, man, I'll show you a video.
There's an essay.
How to become monsters upon respawning.
Monsters will still be monsters.
Players will be able to select a monster class, which they will want to play next.
What?
That's what I'm saying, it's a goddamn essay.
Maybe.
So my best thing, I'd say, is obviously try to complete tasks, but I'd say try to get those survival points, because it might come down to just simple points.
Yeah.
Okay, wait, so like, what do you mean by it's your fault?
What did you do?
Oh, so basically the way that last game worked is whatever color got picked, that's where they would start spawning.
So I wanted them to spawn on the opposite side, so we had as much time to run.
And Sapnap was like the person to my right, so I was like, Sapnap, just get them all to pick the other side.
You meant that it was you!
It was you all along!
I'm sorry!
Alright, I'm sorry.
I had to pay for my therapy for that game.
My bad, my bad, my bad.
Oh my god, it was him.
He was the mastermind.
As a hunter, you just get points for killing someone, but you don't want to hit the wrong people, because then you lose points.
Alright, so this will be divided into two groups, props and hunters.
And then it just leaves my points to get eliminated.
Each participant will start as hunters, with the remaining... oh my god, there's so much reading!
Each round, 8 participants start as hunters, while the remaining will start as props.
A total of 4 rounds are played, and elimination will occur after all rounds have been played.
Winners that start a round will be randomly selected.
If a player dies, they will cool down before they may respawn.
Props become monsters upon respawning, while monsters will still be monsters in both cases.
Players will be able to select which they want to play next.
Each group has specific game objectives they must achieve as...
Oh my god!
Bro, that's...
Okay, props gameplay.
As props, players must survive as much as possible.
If props survive for at least 5 minutes during a set round, the player will earn points.
Props can activate door locks to help running from the hunters, but there is a point penalty by each.
Props will also be given 4 quests to complete.
Upon completing a quest, the player can earn special items and will also earn points.
Props can solidify on other objects by pressing F at a position they would like.
They can also ship-ship each other objects by clicking at them.
Prop disguise includes, but are not limited to, skulls, kettle, holders, pots, statues, chairs, etc.
An anti-AFK system is applied to the game, making props visible to everyone if they stay in the same position for 60 seconds.
The AFK debuff will be removed once the player moves at least 4 blocks away from the position.
If a prop is defeated by a hunter...
There's more?!
Okay guys, there's like an elimination paragraph as well.
As hunters, players must select 1 out of 3 available hunting classes, each possessing different abilities.
These can be used every few minutes to give them some advantage.
These can be selected at the start of each round.
And also, hunters must defeat as many props as possible.
Defeating a prop will give you a point.
Hunters must pay close attention before striking objects.
Once hitting a regular will have deals they will die.
If you participate, all rounds are governed.
Survive 5 minutes, plus 2 points.
Survive 10 minutes, plus 2 points.
Complete a task, plus 5.
Defeat a prop, plus 5 points.
Incorrect prop hit, minus 2.
I read a lot of that.
Alright guys, we gotta be in emote-only mode.
Mud, put us on.
Emote-only mode.
I finished reading 2.
That was like 3 goddamn pages.
That was like a goddamn essay.
Good luck guys.
I hope you make it to day 4, Gumi.
Rest in peace, Gun Teddy.
Rest in peace.
Rest in peace, funny guy.
I'll never know actually how funny you were.
Huh?
You said something, I was peeing.
Gumi, I believe in you.
Make it to day 4.
Do it for me.
Do it for everybody.
Do it for our fans.
Okay, just try to do more tasks than surviving.
Okay.
I think it's good to come down to points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll try my best.
This will be the last time we can talk.
Oh.
Okay, nevermind.
Nevermind.
We can still talk.
Oh yeah, did you put emote-only mode?
Yeah, I'm about to.
Yeah, I did.
Because they said in general that they need to ensure everyone is in it.
Ah.
Yeah, I put mine in just now.
Oh my god.
What a freaking diabolical plan.
To use sap for that.
That shit actually made me crazy.
My chat and I were like mentally drained.
Wait, I actually didn't hear the plan because I was busy reading the rules.
Oh, basically what he did, what your friend did, was that he convinced sap to yell as loud as he can to convince people to go on the other side of the map.
So like, him and his friends would be on the other side.
So the puppet would chase the people on the majority of the colors.
So the people on the other side get to have a free run.
Like a free reset, I guess.
Ah, I see.
So yeah, he convinced sap to yell as loud as he can to put everybody in one square while their group were on the opposite side.
And that was so evil.
I can't believe us spitting on E-Rob's grave was on the main channel.
I can't believe.
Dude, why did they put that on the main channel?
Yeah, we were doing so many other things.
We were doing so many things like feeding the orphans, watering flowers, helping cats out of trees.
We were like, showing people where the eggs are and everything.
Being a good citizen.
And then they show us spitting on E-Rob's grave.
I can't believe it.
This is like, propaganda.
Propaganda?
Why did you use that word?
It's negative propaganda against us.
It's slander!
Oh my god.
This is the longest 5 seconds in the world.
That's crazy that they have to check each and individual stream if we're in emote only mode.
Actually, you've been wrong.
It's easier to be a prop in this game mode.
Why?
It's way easier to be a prop.
Oh, to get tasks, yeah.
What with the new points?
Yeah.
Because I thought they were going to...
Because the hunters get minus 2 points if they hit something wrong.
Yeah, that's true.
So it's kind of doomed.
I'm just like, thinking like, how...
Like, there's so many props too.
Like, what if it's just a hitbox, you know?
Like, the messed up hitbox that freaks you up.
So, I think everybody should get a chance to play hunter once, right?
Or is it like... It could be RNG though.
Yeah, it's RNG.
Yeah.
So, and then like...
But then when you die as a prop, you get respawned as a hunter.
So, we have to also hunt as a prop.
As we die.
Right?
Unless I misread it.
Huh?
I wasn't listening.
Oh!
I said like, if we get caught as a prop, we have to hunt after that.
Yeah, you become a hunter next.
Yeah.
Yeah, so like, it's just like, living as long as you can, doing tasks.
I just... Oh my god, it's just so... There were so many words.
There were so many...
It's okay, they're gonna play a video after this.
Thank god.
The video will help a lot.
I need the visuals.
I need...
I need my Coco Melon.
I need my Coco Melon, please.
Coco Melon.
To be fair, that video on the last game was not helpful at all.
Like, because it implied that you're safe.
Like, you know, that like, it's not Majority.
It didn't even say that in the rules either.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
I...
It was a tiny bit helpful knowing the dolls had abilities and showing which doll had what ability.
Like, the fireball card?
Yeah, yeah.
And that...
Yeah.
I feel like this game is really well-coded though, from that last game.
It's well-coded, but I feel like they should've tested the games more.
Like, I feel like there's like, so many things that could've been adjusted if like, the games were tested a little bit more.
Like, the tiebreaker one?
You remember the tiebreaker on day one?
And how there's like, barely enough time for people to like, do the tiebreaker if they got cursed?
Yeah.
Like, stuff like that.
I got info about that tiebreaker.
Apparently, you can see the person who's cursed, but you can't see the people who aren't cursed.
It's like the other thing.
Oh, so like, the people who are cursed can't even... don't even know where they are.
No, but here, Doki, I'll teach you a trick.
Yeah?
Uh, if you play F5, and you just run around like this, you can scan around the area better.
Oh.
I- I know people keep telling me to play F5, but like, I'm so bad at moving when it comes to F5.
Okay.
Wait, that's a lot.
Dying is bad.
Wait,
that's...
dying is just bad.
Wait, that's like, so long.
You might as well just stand still.
Oh, true.
But still, I feel like...
Okay.
Yeah, that's true.
We should've been talking about strats with them.
Well, I guess we do have to play F5, chat, because it's a prop, so we have to know where people are.
You just gotta, like, when you die as a prop, you become a hunter, so you just gotta stay locked in, no matter what you are, honestly.
Like, either do your tasks, or go for prop kills.
Goomy, goomy, goomy!
Did you guys see the TV below this table?
Made you look.
There's no TV below the table.
I don't believe you.
Evil.
I'm not helping you next time, chat.
I looked.
I'm not gonna lie, I did look.
This one over here looks like a TV.
Can't believe it.
Oh, I'm here!
I'm coming, I'm coming!
Already discussing strats?
Yeah, what's the strat?
Go ahead.
It's 5 points per kill, and it's only 2 for survival every 5 minutes.
So you get so many more points as killing.
So if you can speedrun your tasks fast, and then die, you can probably get a hunter within, like, 5 minutes-ish when you respawn, and then you can just get a lot of points killing people.
And they can't do anything, because they're on respawn.
I mean, depending on how far you wanna, like, try and game the system.
I wonder if, like, props have, like, certain speeds, just like prop hunt.
Like,
the smaller the prop you are, the faster you can be, but you have less HP.
Yeah, because I feel like large items should have more HP.
Like, candle, chair, and something else, right?
Oh my god, there's a squad of FBI.
Bro, they're fucking walking like a squad.
It's like, Mr. President, get down.
Mr. President, get down.
What the heck?
Are they real people?
Are those real people?
They're so coordinated.
What if we say, like, right now, we're gonna turn into, like, a very specific item, like a skull, right?
I think I wanna turn into...
Yeah, a skull probably would be the easiest.
Yeah, the skull or, like, the...
Candles?
Yeah, candles.
There's chairs, too.
I haven't seen a lot of chairs here, though.
It's like...
Yeah, I mean...
Those chairs are very, like, sort of big, like the ones in the kitchen.
Yeah.
I wonder what would be, like, the best spot to, like, hide.
I'm just wondering what the tasks are.
I hope they're, like...
I hope the tasks are, like, somewhat easy.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
Like, I feel like...
I mean, four tasks in ten minutes has gotta be easier.
Yeah, but then I'm, like, wondering if they're gonna be, like, divided into different rooms.
You're gonna see, like, props running around everywhere, trying to get to various rooms.
Yeah.
It's also gonna be, like...
Because there's three different types of monsters with different powers, but we don't know what that is.
Yeah.
Like, if there's one that just has, like, a sensor that there's a monster in the room, you just stay AFK in that room for a minute and wait for them to move.
I think it could be one that gives you, like, a speed boost.
One that maybe helps you find props that are hidden.
And one that... I don't know what the third one could be, but...
Maybe, like, a range ability or some kind.
Ooh.
Oh, my gosh.
Finally, the timer started.
Yay!
And then on the... Like, let's say you're in a tie.
It's a free-for-all deathmatch, so you just, like, want to be with your ally if you have any in there.
And then target the other people.
Wouldn't the tiebreaker be only one person survive out of everybody?
Well, probably because of how many eliminations they need.
So, like...
Like, let's say multiple people have the same amount of points in the bottom 30.
It's like... I think we'll see a tiebreaker.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna get knocked out.
I'm gonna get knocked out.
Oh, my God.
This is not RNG.
This is actually tryhard time.
Yeah, right?
This is not fair.
What happened to the RNG?
RNG.
You know, we made it this far, guys.
We made it to day three.
All four of us?
Okay.
I don't know what kind of copium you have.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
I'll give you guys...
I'll give you guys points if...
Wait, no.
That's colluding.
I was gonna say, I'll give you guys points if you split the money.
Wait.
Okay.
If you guys make it to top 20...
If you guys make it...
I'll give you guys points if you guys split your cash earnings.
If you make it to top 20.
Good luck.
Oh, my God.
Here we go.
You don't even get the video?
Oh, I'm hunted.
I'm hunted.
Die, die, die.
Help.
We're still waiting?
There's more?
What?
Bro, there's...
They just...
They posted more rules.
How are there more rules?
Bro, okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me read this.
All right.
Okay.
We count steps taken?
All right.
I sort of registered this.
I was like, how is there more?
I was so surprised.
I was like, there's more to reading?
I'm crouching up and down in the corner.
Okay.
What is this?
This is it.
This is it, guys.
I feel like...
Guys, I feel like...
When I'm a hunter, I have to play in first person.
I think as a hunter, I would absolutely accidentally hit other things if I wasn't first person.
Because I don't play enough Minecraft to realize where the hitboxes are.
Like, I'm so bad with hitboxes.
Oh my god.
Please show me the video of what the tasks are.
I wanna know what the tasks are.
I'm gonna steal his...
Stealing intel.
Stealing strats right now.
It wouldn't matter anyway because I don't know what I'm doing.
I feel like these Minecraft players know more than me.
Thanks for the free intel.
Loser.
But not really a loser because they might have a chance of winning $70,000 because they play this game more.
But still, thanks for revealing your strats.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
We made it.
Wait, we all have one bar?
Wait.
The heck?
Someone chat was like, we all have one bar.
They kicked us out?
This is everyone getting kicked out.
Okay, now it's okay.
That was crazy.
Someone in the chat was like, everybody has one bar and then we all got kicked out.
Guys, I think they started the server on the opposite side of the world.
On the opposite side of NA.
I'm pretty sure.
NA and SA.
I think they started the server in Japan or something.
Because why did all of us get one bar?
That was crazy.
They are going to fix the server.
Okay, they are going to move us again soon.
My heart, man.
This has been the most stressful rest week of my life.
Oh, Doki.
I got some bad news.
Yeah, what's the bad news?
We all discussed it.
We are going to target you.
Wait, what?
Why me?
Yeah, I'm not going to, but they all want to.
Wait, what?
What did I do?
They just want you out.
Apparently, you are too good.
And yeah, Gumi said she was gunning for you.
Oh, okay.
Now I know you are lying.
Gumi would never throw me out.
You are lying.
We have a pact.
Gumi would never.
Oh my god.
I'm telling Gumi this.
Where is Gumi?
Gumi would never.
She would never rat me out.
Gumi would never do such a thing.
Wait, where is she?
What?
Someone said I gotta buy an account.
Alright, where is she?
I'm going to rat him out.
It's over.
It's over for him.
Gumi would never.
She would never do such a thing to me.
Also, like, how do you target people anyway?
Like, you can't even see any.
You are literally a prop.
That's messed up.
That breaks rule 33.
No negative behavior.
This has to be a positive... Oh wait, I broke rule 33 when I was on the main broadcast.
Hahaha.
Whoops.
Oopsie.
It's okay.
It was in...
It was like...
Like a positive thing that happened there.
Where is she?
I don't know where she is.
Where did she go?
That was actually crazy.
I realized a lot of Minecraft players died during the first game.
Which is insane to think about for me.
Hahaha.
I don't know.
I actually think it's like actually crazy that I lived longer than a lot of like...
A lot of the well-known Minecraft players in this game.
Oh, they're angry about the rules.
They're angry about the rules.
Whatever amount of people... Could it be hunter then?
It's a little silly.
There's like...
Yeah.
It's definitely like speedrunning and then dying.
It's just depending on like how hard the tasks are.
And if you're able to do them all.
Yeah.
A lot of question marks.
I think the cinematic will give a few of those questions answers.
Yeah, that's the thing.
I think some people are tweaking about the rules.
But I feel like the cinematic will make it so much more simpler.
Oh my god.
I'm stealing the strats.
I hear people complaining.
And I gotta steal the strats.
I gotta steal the strats from the speedrunners.
From the Minecraft speedrunners gamers.
Oh, is that the remaining Spanish players?
Is that it?
I thought there was more.
There must be more.
I'm pretty sure.
You know what?
There's 80 of us.
They must have been separated into other groups.
I'm just trying to find Goomy.
So I can rat bad boy out.
Can't believe it.
I almost believed him.
Until he said Goomy threw me under the bus.
After everything she did.
There was no way she would throw me under the bus.
She already wasted so much time.
Like dragging me through the finish line.
For so many days.
Why stop now?
She dragged me to the finish line.
So why would she stop now?
That's when I knew he was lying.
Is she just AFK?
I feel like I haven't bumped into her at all.
Guys, yay or nay?
Is she AFK?
Or is she actually moving around so that I couldn't...
I just barely missed her.
She's not?
Okay.
I'm just unlucky.
Alright, the strategy is to do tasks.
What the heck?
Where could she have gone?
Wait, is that... no?
There's only two people outside.
Oh my god, this is a harder hide and seek than the actual hide and seek game.
This is actually a harder hide and seek game.
Now I'm playing the real minigame.
For example, you know the TNT tag game that they played to get people out?
Intel.
Just gotta be sneaky.
Just wanted the intel.
They know what they're doing?
They're actual Minecraft players.
Wanted to know.
A minute and a half?
Jesus.
That's so long.
Around this side?
No.
Gumi!
You wouldn't throw me under the bus, right Gumi?
Bad boy was saying everybody was gonna throw me under the bus, including you.
But I didn't believe it.
I didn't believe it because I was like Gumi would never.
That's what I said!
I was like, there's no way!
Gumi dragged me to the finish line, why would she throw me under now?
Bad boy's a liar, don't trust him.
He tried to scare me.
He tried to tell me, he's such a bad boy.
Oh man.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter though.
The eggs do nothing.
Okay, but you gotta live to like the last day.
Nah, I'd win.
What if they give everyone 20 eggs?
And they paste in the translation.
Translation, Raptor, translation.
No,
I feel that too.
Okay, I found absolutely nothing.
He's my friend, not your friend.
I have 28.
I heard that they like activate the eggs late too sometimes.
Say him that you're my friend.
Oh, I heard that too.
Yeah, yeah, because someone in the general chat like activated the eggs.
The final egg was activated after half the day was over.
Yeah, that's so...
That's so... that's messed up.
That's actually messed up.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
You know, if a non-Minecraft player makes it to day 4, that's a goddamn win in my book.
Well, there's a lot of non-Minecraft players.
No, there is... you know damn well the majority of the players here that are live are Minecraft players.
The one that Red died to was like the fast one.
Like it was like super speed, like super fast or something.
So I guess that's like a thing.
I hear him coming.
Did you ever hide in the thingy?
No, because they were saying that they camped people.
Oh, I hid in one.
Wait, did it work?
Well, it was busy chasing someone else.
I didn't hide because like people were saying that like the puppet was camping people outside.
Really?
Oh, that's scary.
Yeah, so then I didn't hide.
So I got scared.
Good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
If you see me, run into me.
It's a prop.
Yeah, yeah.
Give me...
Thank you.
Let's go.
Back in my house.
Now we're not one boss.
Oh, wait a minute.
We're not one boss now.
Everybody to the other edge of the corner so you don't...
You can only start as a hunter one round.
Oh, good tech.
Yeah.
Interesting.
How do you know that?
And there's a two minute respawn.
It is.
Yeah, read general chat.
They gave a lot of tips.
Wait, what was the...
Wait, what was the tips?
You can peek.
What do you think?
You are my friend.
Wow, he's a Naruto enjoyer?
And when I'm listening to the intel...
You are my friend.
Are you listening to the intel?
Yeah.
I don't know the lyrics.
We've been in emote mode for like years now.
Only two hours have passed.
I swear, I feel like...
I feel like I've been trapped in this purgatory for like eight years.
Since day one.
Since day one, I've been in purgatory.
I'll remember you guys.
For eight years.
And it's not gonna be me.
I love Minecraft.
Don't worry, Ant.
Ant, we got this plan.
Okay, voice chat will be gone soon, guys.
It's like a farm.
Yeah.
Oh, it's like a...
I feel like...
I feel like one of those pets...
That's had their lifespan extended...
For like way too long.
You know what I mean?
By like ultra rich owners...
And they extend their pet's lifespan...
To like...
Longer than they should have been alive.
In this event.
And Goomy's the owner.
Goomy has extended my lifespan to the point where like...
It should not be possible for me to be here.
I should not...
I'm like blind in both eyes.
Like crawling right now.
I need to wear a diaper.
I'm like, please.
Like how am I still...
How am I still alive?
He was.
Two minutes left.
What?
Keep the respawn timer.
No, that's if he dies.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
No problem, no problem.
It's reduced.
They said it was reduced like...
Wait, that's messed up.
That is crazy.
Why can you hear that?
I know for a fact because I've read all this out loud.
Oh my god.
Somewhere me and Wally noticed that.
You are my friend.
Who are like the non-Minecraft players still alive?
It's me?
It is.
You can't say Gumi because she plays a lot of Minecraft.
Like she plays exponentially a lot.
A large amount.
She's part of like at least two different Minecraft servers.
Like at least two.
Yeah.
Okay, you guys can't talk to me.
So yeah, I don't even know.
I'm talking to myself.
I'm actually curious who's like not a Minecraft player that's still alive.
Yeah, but you have to wait two minutes whenever you die.
Yeah, that's true.
You have to wait two minutes and after everybody's doing it, then like there's going to be less people to kill anyway.
So far what we've seen is very open, but I assume past the corridors it'll be like even more closed off.
I don't know guys, I'm scared.
Dude, your ass is out.
I'm scared too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is a little more disaster-y.
Five minutes.
Another five?
I know we can't sing a song, but can we make up a song together?
Unassociated with the normal Hunter and Spawn period.
Wait, do we have to increase it on our own as well?
See, I feel like when we were singing the clapping hands song, it was feeling good.
It was making my nerves.
If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
But I think doing tasks and then like dying quickly is actually good.
That was, who did that?
Yes!
If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
Clap, clap.
I feel like we're trying to cope.
See, that made me feel better, you know?
I feel better.
I feel lighter.
I feel a little lighter.
We're like inhaling some copium at the moment.
We're gaslighting each other.
It's not gone.
Remember this, if you die...
Game, you die in real life.
In real life, exactly!
Guys, I'm gonna die in real life.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
I've lived through enough.
Oh, thank God.
Wait, again?
Why are you...
Oh my God!
Just eliminate me now!
Just eliminate... Just take me out!
This is how to get you.
This is literally how to get you.
Just eliminate me now.
Oh my God.
Wait, do we need to render to higher than 10?
Increasing?
You're not gonna lag.
Just crank it.
You're not gonna lag, bro.
Just crank it, dad.
Oh my God.
Please.
I think this is psychological torture.
They're trying to push us to our limit.
This is squid game.
This is actually squid game.
This is squid game IRL.
What's your strat gonna be?
Yeah, it's nice, peace and quiet.
I feel like this is real squid game.
This is psychological torture.
I think that should be a good thing.
Yeah, tasks.
They bait us.
They put us in a room that we got in.
Yeah, daily tasks.
And then they take us back to the lobby.
To see who cracks first.
Am I alive, Mr. Turner?
I will try.
I will try, Hannah.
Very good.
Aw, thank you.
I'll do my best.
That was mean.
I want you to win.
Can't we share corners?
I can help you.
You can do it.
Yeah, but we can share corners.
I can share tips with you.
What's the tip?
You first.
Hey!
No, I got no tips for you.
No, I'm not your friend.
No corner for you.
Oh my god.
I'm on my other side.
I'm your friend.
Why?
Man, I love how people are screaming because loud equals funny.
Loud equals funny.
I'm going to be so loud to be so funny.
I'm going to make people laugh.
I'm going to make people laugh by being really loud real quick.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
Scream.
Scream right now, Gumi.
Do it.
You're going to have so many fans.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look, everyone is going to laugh.
You just died!
Shit,
the timing.
I don't want to hear you guys.
Silencio!
Stop speaking Spanish!
That was a cool man.
Hey, shut up.
The grenade.
What?
The fuck?
Heck, the heck.
There's no... there's no task.
What?
What's a puzzle?
No!
This is not... this is a puzzle!
Why didn't we have these puzzles yesterday?
This is an actual puzzle!
We had tasks yesterday!
Yesterday's tasks should have been today's tasks!
Goodbye!
I'm going to be right here.
This is where I'm going to be.
Oh my god.
This is... that's so dumb!
This is a puzzle!
These are puzzles!
These are tasks!
Not the actual puzzles!
No!
I cannot chat to help me!
Chat can't even backseat me on puzzles!
I have to think for my own?
What's the point of being a streamer if we have to do our own thinking?
Wait, what the heck?
Wait, everybody can talk?
Silence!
I'm so stressed.
But then you're giving people free points.
If everyone does that, the round's going to end in like 25 seconds.
Some of them seem pretty easy.
I think it's better to die early.
The task seems hard.
If you do the same thing in the round, it's not that bad.
The timer's longer in the first round.
Guys, this is bad.
I have to think for myself, guys.
I'm supposed to be a puppet for my chat.
I regurgitate everything they tell me.
This is bad.
I spent four years being a streamer to not think for myself.
To not do problem solving for myself.
Now, I actually have to use my brain.
Guys, it's not like riding a bicycle where I can just use my brain again.
Guys, it's not like that.
Guys, I'm really stupid.
I don't know if you guys know this.
I'm really, really stupid.
It's not like that, guys.
That's just great.
50% of my brain cells have been on vacation, and they are not coming back.
They're still using their vacation days.
Is it code for the chest?
Yeah, code for a chest.
Finding a key for a chest.
And then just finding something.
Yeah, and then find a hex chest behind stairs?
Yeah, find a hex chest on stairs.
Okay, but like for the code one, how do you think the code one works?
There will be codes randomly everywhere, I think.
I wonder if the tasks will disappear after someone finishes.
There's no way, right?
You just follow the horn again.
Who's up?
Wait, how come they can...
Is it like puta, bad word?
E or ne?
How do I know that word?
Wait, why do they keep swearing in Spanish?
Really?
Like, we can't swear in English.
Yeah, but I think that's Spanish.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, it is acting.
Oh, wait, no, I mean like...
I don't know.
I thought the green one, the highlights?
Rocks?
I was listening to the freaking cinematic!
You dumb people!
Sorry, I need to take my meds for like five seconds.
Why?
Why is it why?
Because if you're running past another prop, you're going to think it's fine.
You get free hits that way.
Say that again?
The prop one?
Imagine you're running past another prop.
You're going to be like, oh, that's chill.
It could be a hunter.
If you see a prop running, you think there's a hunter behind them.
No, but like, there's a hint that the hunter can be a prop.
No, I know, but why as a prop?
Would you see a prop running?
Like, would you not think a hunter's behind them?
No, they're just looking for things.
Maybe they're looking for tasks, yeah.
Do we think there's only one set of eyes?
Or do we think there's three?
There's three.
And you need to do all three.
All three of what?
You have to do all three of the tasks?
That's so much!
I don't know, the tasks are kind of concerning me.
They're a bit complex.
There's like three chests, right?
I don't know, I think it's learning a little more about the tasks and not speaking.
This is perfect.
The best part is figuring out how to do them and hopefully not dying.
I also think it would be nice to be the hunter the first round just so you can see things.
I agree, I would rather be the hunter the first round.
Whoever starts as hunter gets huge advantage.
I just think it's crazy that being a hunter all you need is five kills and then you get more points than any prop could get.
Being a hunter seems like an advantage.
Oh, so it's that simple?
Yeah.
I feel like I should just survive.
I feel like I should survive instead of doing tasks.
If you have to complete all three tasks to get five points, it's not worth it.
Maybe a skull?
I can't change into a prop for 12 seconds?
I don't know.
I want to be a...
Wait, can I get on top of here?
Alright.
Okay, that's dumb.
Like, the timer is still starting.
How do I lock it in?
This is scary.
Rotation locked.
Oh,
I'm scared.
I don't know how to lock in.
Oh, rotation locked.
There we go.
Whoa.
Guys, I want to know.
Is it like, each points...
Each point you get...
Uh...
Why are they running?
I can't tell.
Each point you get is like...
Each point you get per puzzle?
Or is it like...
You get points for completing all puzzles.
Can you guys let me know that?
Per puzzle?
Or is it...
Uh...
All...
Puzzles.
Okay, yay?
For per puzzle, you get points?
Nay!
For... You get points for all puzzles.
Oh, per puzzle?
Oh, so it does benefit doing puzzles.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Okay, we just have to find stuff then.
Told you, some of these is like, so confusing.
We're supposed to get two points per two minutes.
We live.
I don't know.
Oh!
Oh god.
I don't know where the puzzles are.
It's scary!
Do I even get any points?
Am I even getting anything?
That's a lot of monsters.
I have to move soon.
Please bypass me soon.
Oh, he's lagging.
No!
Did he... No!
He was lagging too!
Wait, I survived longer for two minutes, right?
Wait, let me check the points again.
Okay, survived for five minutes.
No!
I didn't survive for five minutes!
It was five minutes, not two!
I read it wrong!
It was five minutes, guys!
It wasn't two!
Goodbye.
I thought it said two minutes.
Like, bro!
Okay, two minutes.
It's like five paragraphs.
Not even paragraphs.
I swear, the rules are like a thousand words.
It's so hard to retain.
Some of the information.
Bro, how did he know?
I locked it.
I locked my rotation.
Bro, okay, the worst part was he was lagging, so I got so confused.
I was like, is he walking past me?
I was like, is that man walking past me or is he trying to kill me?
He's so... He's lagging.
He's...
Like, why are you lagging as the monster?
Sadge.
Okay, so per puzzle, you can get five.
You can get points.
They made it seem like you have to complete all tasks.
So I got confused with that rule.
Yay!
Let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in.
Let me in.
Oh.
Oh, that's why!
Wait, that's actually bullshit!
It reveals a prop!
So that... I didn't know that!
We had no intel as to what they are.
Oh my god, that's why I was like wondering, how did they find out?
Like, I was so confused.
Like, how did they find out?
I was... I was like a monster.
Wait, how do we...
Bro, what the heck?
Here, press F to reveal.
Okay.
Okay, I know like there's a lot of them.
There are no prop... Yeah!
Oh my god, so that's how!
That's actually messed up.
If I knew a monster had that ability, I would not just sit there.
I would 100% not just sit there.
That's actually so messed up.
Oh my god, that's so smart.
Jesus.
Wait, I don't remember the skull being there.
Actually, I don't remember in general.
I don't remember what the props were.
It's been so long already.
I already forgot.
Oh my god.
Are they actually still there?
Okay, they're not there then.
They're not there.
There's only one prop remaining?
Bro, what?
Oh my god.
Can't believe it.
This ability, the revealing prop ability was actually so messed up.
It was so messed up.
No wonder he knew I was just there.
Please wait.
Who has the most points?
Zero points?
Oh hey, there's me.
Zero points.
That's me.
Wait, we all have zero points.
Oh my god.
I feel like they should've told us what each hunter ability does.
Because, like, if I knew that...
One of the hunters can literally see...
Can literally see what the prop...
I would not have just stood there.
I would've ran away.
Oh my god.
After seeing that, I'm like, what?
It's like, how?
I would've 100% just ran.
Oh my god, might as well just be a goddamn prop.
Being a hunter is just better.
There's, like, no reason, I feel.
There's actually no reason to be a prop.
If I was a hunter, I can just find people.
Do puzzles or something.
Let's all just be skulls.
Just kill me now so I can find props.
Just kill me now in games so I can be a hunter.
It's just worth it.
It's either do puzzles or...
There's no stuff here.
Where are some of the tasks?
Oh my god.
The thing is, I feel like we all wanna be hit by the hunter.
Like, the moment you get hunter, you just... It's like, free.
Reload.
IMO.
All of us is just trying to find, like, the puzzle stuff.
Wait, no!
I wanna be there!
I'm gonna die.
I rather... I don't know.
I rather just die.
There's no reason.
Oh my god.
I literally don't know where the puzzles are.
Hello?
Puzzles?
We're all just running around as headless chickens.
We're all, like, headless chickens right now.
Just running around.
One is an actual chicken!
One of them is even a chicken themselves!
The eyes!
Where are the goddamn eyes?!
Bro, I've been moving for, like, 20 years.
You cannot say that.
Your location will be revealed.
I know!
I've been running for 20 years!
I know my location will be revealed!
Yes!
There's two out of three course paintings?!
I don't even
get Oh, wait.
Oh my god, the fact that I don't even get that point automatically is the worst part.
No!
Please hit the candle and not me!
Please!
The candle!
No!
I was so close!
I got two!
I couldn't find the last painting!
That was so close.
I almost juked them, too.
I almost juked them!
It's GG.
This game is hard.
I think it's really hard because, like, the puzzles are, like, so difficult.
And, like, when you're a hunter, you get more out of it as a hunter.
Like, it's so RNG to the fact that you get more points if you get RNG'd as a hunter.
Versus, like, being an object.
So it's already, like, skewed towards RNG for hunters.
Yeah.
Whoever gets, like, good RNG for that, basically...
Gets points.
Because there's more props to kill, too.
There's a lot of props, too, running around.
And everybody's moving around.
Nobody wants to hide, I feel like.
Like, literally nobody wants to hide.
And then the fact that they have that power to...
See objects.
Like, literally see props.
Is, like, messed up.
I think this game definitely should've been balanced more.
This game definitely feels like it could... It needs a lot of balancing, I feel.
I think they should remove the monster that could literally see props.
Because, like, we already have to move.
I think, like, because, like, IMO, we already have to move anyway.
So there's no reason for a monster to be able to have, like, the sight to see props.
If we're moving.
If we have one minute to move.
Like, I know, like, the cooldown's really hard.
Like, there's a huge cooldown.
But, like I said, we're already moving.
So it doesn't matter.
Like, it's just better to be the Grinner.
It's just easier.
Oh, there's 13 props remaining.
I know you're all running, cuz you wanna do tasks.
Nobody's hiding anymore.
I know that.
I know none of you guys like to hide.
I know that none of you guys like to hide.
Yeah, this has been...
Whoa!
Wait, this room has... Wait, they don't change locations for rooms?
Wait a minute.
I feel like when you know what the puzzles are... Wait, that's not fair!
The puzzles aren't locked.
I think.
I think, like, uh...
The puzzles aren't, like, locked to a specific location.
I feel like, right?
Cuz, like, why would...
Yeah, so, like, I could just go there and unlock...
Wait, that's not fair!
We just, like, run... Yeah!
Okay, guys.
The worst part is that I am directionally challenged.
So I don't really remember where the paintings are.
I guess we just gotta figure out where the paintings are again.
Cuz, like, if... The fact that the puzzles aren't locked specifically...
So, like, that's one of them.
Like, the intel.
This is the north rooms.
And I guess, like...
X...
Uh...
That?
Yeah, so that's north room.
So that's one of the puzzles.
Wait, that's not fair!
Wait a minute.
Why don't they rotate that?
They should at least...
Randomize the location.
I feel like they should randomize the locations for this.
Okay.
Where are the other paintings, though?
Uh...
I feel like people will know where the paintings are.
Better than me.
Cuz I found two.
But I don't know where the others are.
Where the other paintings are.
Oh my god.
Where's the last prop?
I didn't even get to see...
Okay, courtyard.
Courtyard takes us to this chest.
I only have one minute to run to here.
So, like...
Me completing one task should be okay.
Question mark.
I just need to go up the stairs for that.
Goddammit, I wish I could, like, have you guys backseat me right now.
My brain is already tired.
Like...
I'm already tired.
Trying to strategize.
One left.
Wherever they are.
I like the grass.
One left.
Oh my god, this guy might have 5 points.
This guy literally...
Goddammit, I know in this group of 80...
People have, like, photographic memory, so they remember where each prop is.
I can feel it.
I can feel the photographic mem...
Oh shit.
And I'm gonna hit that, but I have 0 points anyway, so it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I already have 0 points anyway.
There's me.
There's me over there.
Bro, people have 5 points?
Oh, it's the task...
It's the task!
That's what I'm saying!
They know where to go!
That's literally what I'm saying!
Because none of the area is randomized!
So they literally are just...
They're literally just going to the same place.
I wonder if the chest stuff is randomized or not.
That's what I'm saying, guys!
Bro, people are hunters, man.
Literally a hunter can kill 5 people and they're safe.
They just need to kill 5.
Come on!
Hunter!
80 people!
Hunter RNG!
Let's go!
Oh
my...
Oh my god, where is the courtyard?
Guys, I don't remember where this stuff is.
Wait, a lot of people are going this way.
That's it!
Follow the stones!
What?
Oh, what?!
Okay, this is dumb.
Oh my god, please.
And then...
Are you goddamn kidding...
Please, for the love... Please, just kill me.
I don't care.
Just...
I can't.
Just kill me.
Just let me have this, guys.
I can't!
I literally can't!
Let me have this, guys!
Please!
Just kill me!
I can't!
I can't even F5!
I can't see!
I literally...
I can't... Their body block is...
I can't even open it!
Bro!
Bro, we're stuck in third person, so I couldn't even...
I couldn't even hit it!
I wanted to go back to first person.
I actually... I was like...
I can't.
Just put me back in first person.
I can't do third POV.
Oh my god.
I cannot do third POV, man.
I can't.
It's actually terrible.
Third POV is actually a crime.
For a prop.
Oh my god.
I mean, that can't be the only prop left, right?
Nice.
Oh my god.
That five kill.
I told you it's better!
Wait, what?
Wait.
That's so dumb.
Can I have that five points, sir?
Please?
No, no, no, no.
Not fair!
No!
I have to wait for...
It's not fair!
I had a cooldown!
Oh my god!
That could've been my points!
I'm sad.
I literally had a cooldown.
It's sad.
Oh my god.
Cooldowns shouldn't be a thing.
I'm gonna say it.
The cooldowns should not be a thing.
Get rid of them!
Down with cooldowns!
Just a killing cooldown, though.
I don't care about the ability cooldown.
Down with the killing cooldown!
I'm not gonna do the chest anymore.
That chest actually messed me up.
That messed me up so much.
It made me so sad.
That would've been an easy ten points, too.
I think that made me so sad.
If all those monsters didn't block me, and I just needed to wait five more seconds, ten points.
Oh my god.
And then the monsters that body blocked me, so I couldn't even see anything.
What the?
Oh, that's the admin.
I was like, what was that?
At least not zero points, guys.
At least not zero points.
That's all that matters.
We made it to non-zero points.
I would definitely wish some of these were in the rules.
I know we already had a thousand words, but like, a thousand and five hundred, I don't mind if we went to a thousand five hundred.
I do not mind.
If I already read a thousand, I could read five hundred more.
I could definitely read five hundred more words.
Wait, there's so many of us!
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, wait.
This is so good.
Oh my god, no wonder they couldn't kill us right off the bat.
I realized why they couldn't kill us right off the bat!
Oh, it makes sense now!
Why they couldn't kill us right off the bat?
Oh my god.
Everything makes so much more sense now.
Oh, there's a bone right here.
There's a bone right...
Wait, what?
What the heck?
Oh, that's not good.
Come on, come on, come on.
Let me munch you.
Yes!
Prop killed down.
Yay!
Okay.
Now to wait another minute.
Now to wait one minute.
Yeah.
I'll just...
Now to wait a minute.
Now to wait 30 seconds.
Yay!
I'm gonna chase you down, sir.
Until it's over.
Until I nom you up.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Come on, 22 sec...
Come on, 15 seconds.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
10 seconds.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Time to nom you too.
Nom, nom, nom.
Come on.
You guys got this, guys.
You guys got this.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I got body blocked too.
You don't get to have this.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Wait, who nommed him?
Wait, that was my nom.
That was my nom.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Yes!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
That was my nom time.
It's my turn to nom.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
You don't get that.
After all the pain I had to go through.
You don't get that nom.
Oh, hey.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Get back here.
Ow!
My nom!
Oh, you have cooldown.
You have a cooldown.
I steal that.
Like how you stole my cooldown.
No, I can't see.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
No, my free nom!
What?
There's no way!
Okay, no.
No!
Are you serious?
Okay, I'm actually mad.
There's no way.
Like, I had so many points.
Because I nommed.
They're restarting it?
What?
Okay, that's actually not fair.
I actually don't like that.
I actually had the best round of my life.
And they're restarting it.
Oh my god.
That made me sad.
That actually made me sad.
I feel like they should just commit to it.
There's no... they should just commit to it.
Like, honestly.
There's no reason to keep...
Because like, everybody...
Because it's RNG for the hunters.
Literally, whoever gets hunters wins.
So it's like, I don't feel like they should just...
They should rerun it.
Because the people who got hunters last time...
There's no guarantee they're gonna get hunters again.
So you might as well just commit to it.
Because they didn't restart the other games when it wasn't fair.
I know a lot of people complain about this game.
Because this game was actually messed up.
But I feel like they should've committed.
Because it took like...
We had a 40 minute delay to set this game up too.
And then...
Like, we already committed 4 rounds to it.
Like, 4 rounds has been committed already.
I don't even know if I made it in too.
Like, I don't know if I made it in.
I just feel like, you know...
We already committed 4 rounds of this.
We might as well just commit to the full...
Just keep going.
You know?
At that point, we should just keep going.
I got the hunted too.
And I nom nom nom nom.
I nom nom nom nom.
I worked so hard.
And I don't get to keep my points.
Oh, I get eliminated anyway.
Like, with the...
It doesn't matter.
I already got eliminated.
Wait, no?
Wait, I don't.
Oh no, I do.
I'm 24.
I got eliminated anyway!
And I still said...
Keep it.
People are now complaining.
Because...
People are like...
Some people kept going.
Like, some people actually stopped playing.
Because they said they were gonna rerun it.
So people are mad.
Cause like, now they are in a lose-lose...
Situation now.
They're in a lose-lose situation.
Because they said, like, keep it.
But because if they kept it...
A lot of people actually...
Like...
Because like...
Wait, are we keeping it?
I'm eliminated.
Oh, apparently the chest...
The chest was broken.
Remember that chest?
Cause I don't even know are we eliminated or not!
Apparently, you know that chest?
Where I was like, what the heck is this chest?
You know?
I was like, what the heck is that chest?
That chest was broken!
For everybody!
Nobody was able to open that chest!
I'm reading the general!
Nobody...
Was able to read that.
Nobody was able to open that chest.
Oh my god.
People are mad.
People are so mad.
Yeah, there's some crucial info not to be given.
Yeah, people are complaining about the fact that...
Hello?
Oh my god, people are so angry right now.
I'll be honest, I was really annoyed throughout the game.
I just did not give a fuck at some point.
Yeah, I was like...
I was complaining cause like...
I didn't know...
They told us the hunter abilities...
That one of them can literally see the prop.
So what's the point of hiding?
They have the ability to see a prop!
And I didn't know!
Yeah, but when you start out, you don't know.
So I stood still.
Cause I was like, oh okay, I have like 50 seconds.
And there was like 3 hunters around me.
And then one of them just walked up to me and killed me.
So I was so confused.
I was like, what the heck?
And then I looked at the hunter abilities and I was like...
Oh, if I knew that that specific monster can see props...
I wouldn't have stood still.
I would have been like...
What the heck?
It feels very...
It's hunter-sided.
It's very...
It's overly hunter-sided.
Yeah, no, 100%.
Um...
I don't know, I...
And like, the puzzles were all the same area.
Yeah, so hunters knew where to camp.
I saw like 5 different people camping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, I had a key and they were camping the chest.
Like, it was just Jover for me.
Yeah, like, it was just no point.
Like, cause it was all just like...
There.
I feel like at that point...
Someone was like, you guys are a crime because you don't wanna die.
No, because it was bullshit.
Wait, is that...
Guess who complained about that?
You see that?
What?
Sap.
Wait, but Sap got eliminated.
Yeah, but he's like...
He's a millionaire.
Yeah, but then right after that...
He was like, that was the worst game I've ever played.
Like, I don't...
If they run back any other game...
I think it'd be fine, rather than re-running.
Yeah, I feel like it was just...
I was annoyed, I was actually...
I feel like...
The rules for the hunter...
The hunter abilities should've been given to us.
If they already wrote a thousand words for rules...
Um...
They kinda did give us the hunter's abilities in the video.
But...
Not really.
It wasn't told to us.
Uh, they did, they did.
They did?
They said the red one changes into a prop, the black one...
The black eyeball one changes into a...
No, the red one can see props.
No, there's two red ones.
Oh!
The red dinosaur one has...
Can reveal props for a bit to itself.
I didn't...
I didn't register that.
Cause people were talking too, so I didn't register it quite well.
Yeah...
I was really annoyed when people were...
Yeah, it's just... I don't know, I feel like...
And then the fact that they were saying we're gonna re-run it...
And then, like, people actually stopped playing...
Was like...
And like, apparently a couple people, like...
Stopped...
A couple people actually...
Stopped playing...
And got eliminated because they heard it was gonna be re-run.
Holy shit!
Sap is angry!
Running a different game is not an option.
Don't eliminate anyone.
Just do more limbs for other games.
That game was shit.
You know what?
Sap's on our side.
Oh my god...
So they're not running any other games...
And they want to re-run that same game...
Dude...
Running the same game doesn't change anything.
It's so hunter-sided.
It's just hunter-sided.
I got hunter too!
I got hunter.
I saw you catch up in points.
Yeah, I literally caught up because I got, like...
Four kills.
And the thing is...
I tried to get killed early...
And there were just fuckers dancing around with props.
Because, like...
Why would you kill a prop if you're ahead?
And like, you don't...
If you kill them, it's like less props for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So they were camping other props too.
I saw like three people just...
Running around with props for fun.
Yeah.
It's actually...
I feel like...
That one was actually...
That one was actually messed up.
I feel like...
Oh, yeah.
And the thing is, there's so many.
There's 80 of us too.
So, like, the fact that there's like...
80 of us...
There's gonna be a lot of complaining.
No, like...
Once the event ended...
Or the round ended and we got eliminated...
I saw the general chat move like 20 messages.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's just like...
I was looking and I was like...
Oh, my God!
It's so fast!
Nobody is happy!
Damn, I'm just hopping on Valorant.
Oh, my God.
Wait, was the chest broken?
Because, like, people were complaining that the...
Yo, I was...
My chat was laughing at me because I was like...
Why can't I open the chest?
And then people were laughing at me.
I didn't realize the chest was broken.
I just gave up.
No, the chest was broken.
You can't click the middle part.
I just gave up.
Yeah!
That was it!
I couldn't click the middle part!
I was so confused.
I thought I was being stupid.
I was like, why can't I click the middle part?
I'm so confused.
My chat was laughing at me.
I thought it was me.
But it's not me.
It wasn't me.
Dude, someone just said, Just give 1000 to everyone.
Bro, okay.
I agree.
1k for everyone.
1k for getting to top 80.
Minecrafters don't need 70k.
That shit was so annoying.
I think I went fucking non-verbal.
Because I was just so annoyed that I was getting cammed.
Or like, this and that were happening.
I kind of just went it out.
And the fact that it's like 80 people.
80 people.
Like, 8 people gets to be hunter.
But there's not enough hunter spots for everybody.
I'm turning off emote only for now.
Yeah, me too.
How do you turn off emote only?
I don't know if my mod is still awake.
Oh my god, am I modding your channel?
I know I am, nevermind.
You are, you should be.
Let me check.
Oh no, my moderator is still awake.
Moderator, can you?
Oh nice, thank you mod.
Alright guys, now you can yell.
It was awful, I know it was awful.
You guys can yell now.
That shit was so fucking bad.
Yeah.
Like, I understand the inherent like...
The way they wanted to do it.
I thought they would at least split lobbies or something.
Yeah.
If they split lobbies, that would make sense.
No, and it took like...
It took like 40 minutes of prep time.
It took like literally 40 minutes of prep time.
Just for it to not be...
There was a cooldown of 1 minute for the hunters.
Yeah, there was.
Hunters get like a 1 minute cooldown.
But if you start as hunter, I literally got like...
20 points with the cooldowns.
Yeah, cause like...
Once you start as hunter, everyone is literally running around trying to do tasks.
Also, they didn't like...
So it's so easy.
I get killed like right off the bat.
And I couldn't tell if you could redo the same task.
If I knew that, I would've stayed at the same task.
Wait, you can?
Yeah, it seems like...
The tasks reset each round.
Yeah.
If they're not gonna randomize the location, make there be like a barrier so the hunters can't camp it.
Yeah, I think so.
Like, if they make a barrier around a task, At least it like, lets a prop get some points when they're camping that shit.
Cause like, on the very first round, I got the key for the chest.
And there was just a hunter standing on it right away.
Like, I couldn't do nothing.
And then I got chased by another hunter cause they saw I had the key.
Yeah.
And then, it's just the fact that like...
The puzzles didn't rotate.
And people were just doing the same task over and over again.
And they just had like a pathway too.
Like a path...
If the puzzles...
Like, if the puzzles themselves randomized, it would've been more fair.
Because people don't have like a set pathway.
And the fact that they decided that at the very last game, that it's not working.
And then they said it in the middle of the game for everybody.
It's what was messed up.
They should've just like, said it in the first round.
If they didn't...
If they did not say like, we should reset.
Then like, people would've been fine.
But the fact that they said, we should reset.
And...
Um...
Then like...
Then they would've been...
Everybody would've been more agreeable with the elimination.
But yeah, a couple of the tasks were definitely broken.
Yeah.
I didn't even realize certain...
I didn't even know certain items had certain abilities.
Oh my God.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Apparently, some people didn't get Hunter and they're mad.
Because like, they couldn't make it.
Just rerun the...
I don't wanna rerun the dog game, man.
The admins literally said they can't rerun any of the past ones.
I don't understand why they couldn't rerun any of the past ones though.
I don't know.
Okay, let's make our own Twitch rivals.
Yeah.
You know, they actually offered for me to...
Why did you say yes?
What?
Did you say yes?
Is it bad?
No, I'm asking.
Did you say yes?
Well, we're still...
I don't know any other details.
They just asked me if I wanna do a Twitch rival.
If you wanted to?
I thought it'd be cool.
I'm asking.
Did you say yes?
I don't...
If you say yes, code a good one at least.
Make sure it's a good one.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, because like your reputation gets hit for...
For having a bad one.
And it's not even your fault.
Not necessarily.
Well, they will say like...
Oh, remember that...
HennaXXRose Twitch rivals that happened?
That one was shit.
Wait.
It will be tied to your name.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's why.
That's why.
That's why it's like risky.
Oh my God.
There's no winning.
There's actually no winning.
They're just talking.
Honestly, like...
Elimination or not, I kind of don't give a fuck at this point.
I think like...
I like how people are like...
I got propped four times and made it.
And then, they're like...
Well, to be fair, they are full on Minecraft players.
So they know how to...
They have like set routes and stuff.
I'm too stupid for set routes, man.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't remember where the things are.
Yeah, people are just mad because...
Some people...
Some people got eliminated because of the announcement.
Yeah, some people...
Literally are just...
Bam!
Clicking shit just for...
To test things out because they heard there was a rerun.
Yeah.
A lot of people lost a lot of points because of that.
Yeah, that's so true.
You gain more from being a hunter because like...
As a prop, you only gain four points.
For surviving ten minutes.
When a hunter can get...
No, for five minutes.
I didn't either.
I survived four minutes at most.
Because there's just too many hunters.
By the time four minutes hit...
There's just too many hunters.
And like...
Yo, whoever that is in the fucking general chat...
Is sucking mad dick.
What do you mean you got eliminated and thought the event was fun?
Like the last game?
Or the whole entire event?
I obviously thought that last game was fun.
You're pissing me off.
Dick rider!
That last game was not fun.
Don't lie.
That last game was so frustrating.
The Twitch Rivals guy is typing.
Oh shit.
That's so funny.
There's no way.
I'm about to launch Pokemon.
If I fucking give a fuck.
What the hell?
The Twitch Rivals person is...
Is typing now.
The thing is...
If they say eliminate all the people...
They're gonna have 30 really angry...
Well, not 29.
No, 28 because I don't care anymore.
28 really angry streamers.
And I think like...
I think SadSnap is in it.
I think...
I think Snap is one of those 28 really angry...
Players that got eliminated.
Oh, this head?
Because of the lack of clarity in the game mechanics of PopPun...
We've determined that the game did not work fairly.
We invite all players for today...
Who participate in this game to join us tomorrow.
Tomorrow we will run three events...
Starting with doll game.
And the 30 people who should have been eliminated...
Will be eliminated then.
What?
So you're making us fucking get eliminated tomorrow?
I don't get it.
What are you saying?
What?
We will run three games starting with the doll game.
And the 30 people who should have been eliminated...
Will be eliminated then.
I guess we're gonna play doll game...
And then we're gonna see who are the 30 people...
That are gonna...
I don't know.
Why doll game?
That was so...
That was...
I think I hated that game the most.
That game was so anxiety and anxiousness.
I think we should go Sky.
I think we go Sky, Doki.
What do you mean Sky?
What does that mean?
I can't say it, but...
Type it.
Alright, I'm gonna type it.
I think we should...
Oh my god.
This game is pissing me off.
Guys.
Oh my god.
People are not happy.
Even though we're re-running...
Because we have to come back tomorrow.
So people are not happy.
But there's one person...
That's extremely happy.
And it's the one person...
Everyone knows.
Very happy right now.
Because if they didn't...
They would've been eliminated.
And they...
I bet you Twitch staff did not want to piss them off.
Wait, they're kind of spitting.
Wait, hold on.
Pause.
The person typing in chat is kind of spitting.
Wait, why?
What did they say?
They think that the people who...
Made the game...
Made it today should have to play.
And I kind of agree with that.
Yeah, I agree with that honestly.
But the thing is they have to eliminate 30.
Or they cut the eliminations to like 15.
Well, then that would make sense for the later games.
Because I think they like...
Coded it specifically.
Where um...
Where they're forced...
Sorry, I'm fucking playing...
Poker Rogue right now.
Where they're forced to um...
Have a set amount of people per day.
Yeah, oh that's true.
Like per lobby.
That's true.
What did AntVenom posted?
Someone told me to look at what AntVenom tweeted.
They didn't tweet it.
Wait, they didn't tweet it to say anything.
What do you mean?
Or did it say something in my chat?
Dude, I don't think AntVenom himself would go out of his way to go into your chat.
Yeah, I know.
That's why someone was like, look at what AntVenom...
What did they... I don't know what they said.
I was like, who's AntVenom?
I don't even know who that is.
Omegalul.
I was like, who?
Oh my god, you see like people pulling up clips?
What?
I do, I do see it.
Join our voice channel?
Oh my god.
No.
He's being taken.
Oh my god.
Wait, why are they taking this person?
Did this person complain a lot?
I think this person...
This person wrote an entire...
Oh, that's the one that wrote like three paragraphs of why it's justified to not rerun?
Yeah, yeah.
Like the one that was like, was the game not fair?
Yes!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my god, they're kidnapping them.
They're kidnapping them to talk in voice.
It's Chover.
It's so Chover.
Oh my god, people don't even want to play anymore.
People are like...
Like, this is messed up.
I don't even want to play anymore.
I think they should just give us the money.
Honestly, yeah.
Dude, just spread it.
Yeah, at this point.
I think that's the only thing that can make everybody happy.
Just spread the money.
Because like...
I mean, if it's like...
Yeah, like, just split from the 70k.
Because even so...
Like, they still get like...
Like, 30k.
That's still a lot of money.
Yeah.
That's like the most...
That's like more than any other Twitch rivals.
Or not even that.
Just give like 500 each.
That got eliminated.
No, the thing is...
First place gets 70k, chat.
That's the thing.
First place gets 70k.
So if they take like...
To like all the remaining players that got eliminated...
Then like, at best, not even like...
They can still keep 50k.
Yeah.
The first place can at least keep 50k.
And that's still a lot of money.
50k is still a lot.
There's...
Oh my God, there's another thing.
There's more?
Dude...
I don't even want to look at that.
Wait, where's the more?
No, they're just typing.
Oh no, no.
They're just saying tomorrow will run 3 events starting with a doll game.
I guess like...
I guess they meant like...
30 people will just be eliminated in general with a doll game.
God, a doll game was so strange.
I feel like they definitely need to adjust the doll game.
I feel like...
It shouldn't be...
It should be like...
If you get a safe doll, you should be just safe automatically.
Sorry.
Do you see that?
I'm wearing the keg.
They put skull emojis right away.
That's so...
That's so tone deaf.
That's like read the room.
For context, basically...
In announcements, they add all of us and said...
Don't forget that Twitch Rivals will be raiding and gifting 25 subs to your lucky random channel at the end of the day.
Just make sure to be streaming.
Everyone's mad.
People are mad right now because...
It's so...
Oh my god.
And then people are reacting to it and putting like...
Skull emoji and keg.
W.
Dude, the first thing I saw was a skull emoji right away.
Yeah, yeah.
The skull emoji.
And someone reacted with the question mark.
Okay, whatever happens...
Not gonna lie, this was content.
It was good content.
Yeah, this is...
It's so fun to see drama...
When you're not involved in it.
You get to watch it in the sideline.
As everything's getting cooked right now.
I like how someone was like...
Please tell me where the last egg is.
Can you guys tell us where the last two eggs are?
Do you know where the last two eggs are?
Well, if we weren't eliminated, we would tell you.
Wait, what?
Wait, that's messed up.
Do you see that?
Where?
The dolls are ping-based.
So people get spawned randomly...
In the same position during the whole...
So if you're closer, you immediately get targeted.
So if you have worse ping, you basically spawn late.
Yeah, I know that, but apparently...
If you have bad ping...
You're closer to the doll.
That's actually messed up.
Wait, what?
That's so messed up.
I did not know that.
I'm mad at you.
Wait, what?
I posted a screenshot of my PokeRogue.
Whoa, you're lagging!
You're lagging!
Wait, 5UP made it in.
Oh, you know what?
Great, great for 5UP.
5UP made it in, but he's arguing...
He's representing the people that got eliminated.
Because he was...
He was mad that the chest was broken.
That's so funny!
Like, he made it...
But like...
He's really mad...
At the chest being broken.
That he's fighting for us.
It's about the principles.
He's a real one.
He's representing...
True, to be fair...
He would've had more points.
He could've had so much more points.
If that shit wasn't broken.
That's funny.
That's so funny.
Hey, someone's gotta represent us.
We're not even arguing, we're just watching.
I bet you they just didn't want to make that person mad.
It's true!
Because he was really mad.
Guys, if you could've seen...
How mad he was.
Guys...
Yeah, they can't code that in time.
I guess they could do that for the dolls.
Someone said I got...
Wait, is Sylphie trolling?
There's no way you can get 47 points as a hunter.
Oh, over all the rounds.
She's also one of the hosts.
She's also a host.
Wait,
as a hunter?
Yeah.
Wait, how the heck did she get 47?
She probably just hunted multiple rounds.
Wait, she got hunter multiple rounds?
Wait, I thought you could only get it once.
Wait, that's not fair.
Girl, that's what we were talking about!
Yeah, I didn't realize!
I thought you'd be like, oh you can get it once and you won't get it again.
But that's actually rigged!
If you can get double hunter!
Wait a minute!
Okay, now I'm mad.
Now I'm mad.
Now I'm gonna start typing.
Now I'm gonna be mad too.
I went in and be like, well at least you can get hunter only once if you do get it.
But you get multiple hunters?
Yeah, there are some people who got hunter multiple times.
What is this RNG?
So it's like, Doki is typing now.
Did you see me pop up?
What?
Wait, give me a second.
I think I should also win.
Yeah, I'm pumped for you.
I think we should not rerun the game, but I think you should give us our money.
Wait, honestly?
Just re-divide the prizes and give 500 to the people that got eliminated.
I added the mouth there so people won't take it too seriously.
But I'm sort of serious.
I'm not joking.
Hold on, don't worry, I'll support you.
Wait, she's cooking.
I'm probably satisfied, I got 500 dollars for 3 days of this.
I'll take that.
Oh my god, look at what's happening.
What?
Look, look in the chat.
They're fighting.
People are mad about the copyright stuff.
To be fair, they told people that...
Oh my god, he's calling...
Look at him.
He's calling out people reacting.
Oh my god, he's calling people out for the music stuff.
If you guys are in the Discord right now...
Minecrafters are fighting.
They're actually fighting.
They're fighting.
Shakira, Shakira.
Somebody called out another Minecrafter for playing music and they responded, cry.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit, I'm enjoying this now.
Wait, I'm down.
I'm down to keep going if I get to see stuff like this.
Fight, fight, fight.
Minecraft fight.
Take it to bedwars.
They should just take it to the bedwars to settle it.
I think you guys should 1v1.
I think you guys should just take it to the bedwars.
I think you guys should take it to bed.
Who said that?
Some repressed rage there.
Oh my god.
Just give us $500.
I'm satisfied.
$500.
Guys.
I think Doki was right.
I think they should give us money.
That's all.
Tongue out emoji.
I like how both of us, we don't care anymore.
We don't even want to come day 4.
Just give us the money.
I think $500 per person is good.
$500 per person who got eliminated.
We already invested 3 days of this.
Yeah, suck my balls.
Yeah.
Oh man, if you guys could only see...
If you guys could only see the skirt fight.
It was actually so good.
I say revive everyone from the whole event.
Let's all donate and double the prize pool.
Instead of $70k, the first place player can get $140k.
The ad was like, please feel free to log off.
We're continuing to discuss this.
They're still working on a solution.
Girl, is there no solution?
What's going on?
Bro, just end the tournament.
Just end the event.
Amazon,
we know you have a lot of money.
Just increase the prize pool and give all of us free money.
Amazon, please!
Amazon, Jeff Bezos, please!
Twitch is losing money every year.
If you guys didn't know that, chat.
It's been in the negatives for years now.
They have not been a profit, by the way.
I think Twitch...
For Amazon, Twitch is like a...
What is it called?
A tax write-off type deal.
They know it doesn't profit.
But they're only doing it because it's a nice tax write-off.
Yeah.
It's like a vanity project.
A loss leader?
What does loss leader mean?
Guys, let's learn economics while people are fighting.
Double just typed, can I get revived?
Yes, I think we should revive him.
Now that he said something, I agree.
Yeah, I agree.
I like unfairly took his spot.
Someone's like, is there a call going on?
They want in.
They want in on this.
I'm glad all of you guys like drama.
Because I saw...
I don't know if it's the same for you, Gumi.
But I actually had more people watching now.
Just to know what the fuck is going on.
Just to know what the drama is like right now.
People are watching the game over screen.
To know what's going on in the Minecraft wars.
I think I stopped them from talking.
I think...
No!
I don't want to get in a call.
Wait, but we get in a call and mute ourselves.
We can listen to the fight.
I know.
Oh my god.
I think it'd be like world star.
It's going to be like world star.
I think people...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what is he saying in Spanish?
Deep L?
Deep L-ing is?
Deep L-ing?
See you tomorrow.
See you tomorrow, GGs.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's just a see you tomorrow.
I like how like...
Everybody that was arguing, mostly...
They shut the fuck up.
What?
They all shut the fuck up.
No, no, no.
I meant like...
It was all in English.
Oh my god, they're beefing.
Look, look, look.
Your takes were not good.
Can I join a voice chat?
Oh my god, they're going to fight.
Oh my god.
They're going to go to voice chat, guys.
Goddamn.
Use your words.
Talk to me in person.
Don't use your fucking...
Don't type to me.
See if you can say it.
Look me in the eye and say it to my face.
Turn the webcam on.
And look me in the eye.
And talk to me like that.
Oh my god.
Bro, are they going to a different...
Minecraft server...
To talk.
Wait, that's so funny.
Did you see that?
They're not even going to use this server.
Oh my god.
Do you know what that stands for?
What?
Oh man, it's like ultimate hardcore or something.
Oh my god.
It stands for hardcore minecrafters.
It's like an exclusive minecraft server.
An exclusive minecraft server voice chat.
Guys, they're not even going to argue in this server.
They're taking it to the ultimate hardcore minecraft server.
With all the ultimate hardcore players to duke it out.
In voice chat.
Holy fuck.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
They're going to the S rank minecraft server.
The fight is not for us peasants.
Oh my god, they're not even going to let us watch?
They're not.
I know.
Why are they tired of us typing?
Tell Amfrost to give us an invite right now.
Amfrost.
We want to listen in.
It's not fair.
The content we're missing.
I want to know DT, let me in.
I can't believe it.
The off screen Goku vs Frieza.
Oh my god, he sent me an invite.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Guys, we're in the ultimate hardcore server.
Wait, I don't have a role.
I don't have a role.
Give me a role.
Oh my god, bro.
Bro, I see all the minecraft players, guys.
Oh my god.
They gave us a role just to like...
Just to look at the waiter.
We have no role.
We have no role so we can't see.
He's the owner of the server.
He's literally the owner of the server.
Give me a fucking role.
Give us a role right now.
We want to listen to this fight.
Guys, we're so cool.
Guys, we're so cool that we're at the ultimate hardcore minecraft server.
I'm in.
I'm not in yet.
They gave me a role too.
It's because you're offline.
The rare online moment.
I just want you to know I haven't been online for 3 months.
Or not 3 months, for like...
If anything...
We can't talk to each other.
We can type.
I'll type to you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll read it out loud what you say to my chat.
I'll join.
I'm not in yet.
I don't have a role yet.
I told him to give me a role.
Wait, what about my role?
Bitch, I told him to give him a role.
You just have to wait.
We're missing information right now.
You type me the info.
I'll read it out in the chat.
I'll wait like 1 minute.
If he doesn't give me a role, I'm gonna yell at you.
Okay, I'll call you back then.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, Gumi is gonna give us the insider knowledge.
I still don't have a role yet.
I still don't have...
We're...
Sad.
They're talking about the spawn spots.
They're actually beefing!
I need to know.
Oh my god, they're actually beefing!
I'm missing good beefing content.
I can't believe it.
No!
Minecraft streamers are wild.
Bro, apparently they're actually arguing.
Oh my god.
They're talking about spawn spots.
What the heck does that mean?
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
We're gonna...
We don't have the role yet, so I'm gonna steal Gumi's content right now.
Guys.
I'm gonna steal Gumi's content.
What the heck is this nerd talk?
Oh my god.
What the heck?
Guys,
I got the role!
No more stealing content!
Okay, I'm going in, I'm going in.
I'm going in.
Bro!
There's...
There's 20 people!
There's 17 people in this car!
Yo, sorry dude.
Sorry dude.
That was interesting.
Yo, sorry to like...
Yo, sorry to like interrupt, but...
You guys should probably read what someone said.
Don't read it out loud.
You should read it.
That would like...
Yeah.
Hashtag VC.
No, I don't have the role to look at that way, do I?
Yeah, I figured.
That's what I was thinking as well.
Yeah, I figured as much.
Oh my god.
I mean, I just feel like eliminating 30 people off of a...
Mad RNG game is a bit crazy, bro.
Yeah, but isn't that the same...
Isn't that the same thing in like the Rock, Paper, Scissors game we played?
No, they can't hear me.
I muted myself on Discord.
I muted myself on Discord, guys.
You can stack a group with your friends.
Like, I think a lot of people work in the same circles with their friends.
Bro, this is a weird fight.
Like, I had an alliance of maybe five, six people.
If you...
Queue into your friends...
Yeah, you just queue your friends.
Well, you know, I'm not saying it's fair.
Yeah, no, you're allowed to hear it.
You're allowed to hear it because other people are showing it.
Other people...
Other people are showing the nerd fight right now.
We're meant to hear this.
Everyone else is streaming this cop.
Bro,
is this what Minecraft players talk about?
Is this what they argue about?
Bro, if this was an FPS game right now...
I'm going to say it.
If this was an FPS game...
And there's disagreements...
This is going to be...
It would be so much less civil.
It would be so much more civil.
FPS gamers will start saying the most fucked up shit.
This is actually like a nerd fight right now.
It's different because that's the mechanic of the game.
The mechanic of the game is that you can lie to each other...
And do that to try and get points.
Whereas with this, there was no mechanic of the game.
If you got hunter round one...
You did not have to play the rest of the rounds.
You could have just killed everyone in the first round.
This is so civilized.
This is an actual debate club right now.
No, I've seen Apex with a lot of people argue.
Nerd fight.
This is an actual argument.
That's the only thing that's civilized though.
You could look at past games and say that.
Where are we drawing the line on what games get re-run or what doesn't?
I've seen fucked up shit when Apex and Overwatch gamers start arguing.
When FPS gamers start arguing, it's actually so messed up.
They get real personal unga bunga.
I feel like I'm in a debate club.
Here's my thing.
There was a lot more factors that were completely RNG.
If you spawned on the east wing, you spawned next to all three paintings.
So you could just run to all three paintings immediately.
And get 10 points, 15 points, however many points it was.
Just for the paintings.
I'm at upper volume so you guys can hear the argument better.
By the time they run to the east side, the hunters are coming out of the door killing them.
So there is no balance in the idea of...
Sure, but there's more randomness.
But we're saying that that's just not a good argument to re-run.
I'm not saying we should re-run.
Let me make that clear.
I'm not even saying that it should be re-run.
I'm not saying that's the solution.
I'm saying that game should have never been played.
That's the only take that is actually real.
That game was completely unbalanced.
And it shouldn't have been played.
On the first round, a hunter got 25 points.
And that's just an example of one hunter on the first round.
In a single round.
That's guaranteed.
That's only five kills.
One thing I'm saying about that is...
Sure, the hunting was OP.
But let's be honest.
When we were all sitting there and looking at the points.
We all knew that the hunting side was OP.
Everyone knew the hunting was going to be OP.
This is great.
I'm glad I made it to day three.
I'm so happy I made it to day three.
Yes, we know the hunter is OP.
There's not much we can do about that.
But...
If the hunter is so OP.
And a task isn't working.
Then the survivors are playing at such a huge deficit.
What's going on?
That's a goddamn nerd fight.
That's what.
You can't run the game with the survivors already at a disadvantage.
I'll show you guys.
I want to show you guys how many people.
There's a lot of people in this gauntlet.
Because if you spawn at that middle chest.
The turning one.
For me personally, which I spawned twice.
Fiddled with it for a solid minute.
Does not work for me.
So you can't have that as an argument.
And so if I spawn there.
And then I just lose the advantage.
Because now I'm at 20 seconds to find the other tasks.
And then the hunters just beeline it.
Bro, is this what being in a Minecraft community is like?
People fight like this?
And so I'm just fucked now.
You're not allowed to!
All the fiddle of the time and everything doesn't matter.
The only thing that actually matters is if the game is genuinely buggy.
Is this every day for them?
It doesn't matter how unbalanced anything is.
It doesn't matter how left or right anything happens.
If things work for some players and don't work for other players.
And they're doing the same inputs and the same everything.
That's what I can give up.
That's just the only thing that makes sense.
Nothing else about the balancing matters at all.
Everyone's going into the same game.
If it just genuinely doesn't work.
Then that's the only thing that makes sense.
Who?
Iskall?
He's adding another person to argue?
Like the problem with the tomorrow.
Is like one thing that's gonna happen.
Did you hear that?
Can we add the other guy?
He has some good points.
Another fighter has joined the lobby.
It did the same thing.
Where it just kind of spawned somewhere.
If we had to eliminate six people that last round.
And there's only one color.
And it spawned right in front of you.
That's not fair.
This is like a whole new world for us guys.
The solution's fixed.
It's still random if you spawn in front of it.
That's a strategy.
Here comes a new challenger.
No, if you don't know where you're spawning.
I'm literally like the fly on the wall right now.
No, what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is.
You know how when it got to the end of the game.
And there was like only one color left.
It just kind of just.
Put it down somewhere.
And you didn't really get to choose.
It just kind of ended up spawning in front of you.
Because there was only one color left.
Imagine like the last round of tomorrow.
When you need to get rid of six people.
And it just spawns right in front of you.
Like that's just unlucky.
My argument.
My only argument for that is.
There is like the safe zones.
Which I'm hoping they would put more in.
And then that's a strategy.
Run to the safe zone.
Oh my god.
Why are they strategizing now?
You can't use that in an argument.
The only thing that I can get behind at all.
There's two things that the avants did wrong.
And this is an objective fact.
There's two things that they did wrong.
That would cause the game to have to be replayed.
As if there was genuine bugs.
Affecting people playing.
That stuff didn't work.
There were things that maybe some people could do on low ping.
But other people couldn't do on high ping.
And they didn't test it.
That is valid.
The only other thing that's valid.
Is they cancelled it in the middle of the fourth game.
And some people trolled in their heads.
Knowing that it was going to be cancelled.
Because that's what they said.
And now they're going to walk it back.
Every RNG argument, we're not going to get anywhere.
There's no point in even talking about it.
Every single game you will ever play.
In any game.
In Minecraft.
Half of the games in this event.
Were made to have RNG in them.
Because they wanted it to be fair.
To the lower placing players.
That's why there's RNG factors.
The whole entire point of this event.
Was to maybe see.
Some random VTuber.
Versus Feinberg.
That's me!
I'm the random VTuber!
Oh my god!
Guys, there's a lot of people in this call.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
So that's the point.
It's designed like that.
The RNG argument literally has no stake.
No impact on anything.
It's me!
They're talking about me!
I think that argument changes my mind.
Because I was against you on this.
I think that the RNG.
The balance of the game was.
For a $100,000 event.
That's my argument.
That was despicable.
To put $70,000 on the line.
And then make you play that game.
It's for sure not fair.
I don't think anyone disagrees with that take.
All these games we've been playing.
I go into it just being like.
I could just randomly.
Like that curse one.
I could randomly just spawn with it.
And everyone just runs away from me.
What was I supposed to do at that point?
Now they're doing the doll game.
Which to me was $70,000.
I agree 100%.
It's me!
The best solution out of all of this.
It sucks to say.
Calculate the points of the people who got fucked over.
And then just move the people on.
Because at the end of the day.
I think running it back.
You guys saw the thing in VC.
Running it back isn't really the best idea.
No matter what people are going to be fucked over.
So I think the best thing you can do.
The best thing you can do in this situation.
Is just calculate the points.
Because obviously.
I'm in the thick of the Minecraft drama.
There was bugs right?
But it's not like.
The way they make it sound.
It's only one person experienced a bug.
That is not true.
I had the checkbook.
And you all laughed at me.
Because you thought I fucked up.
That is not true.
You all laughed at me.
The best thing they can do.
Is just count the scores.
Get a bunch of people and count the scores.
I don't agree.
Because you thought it was possible.
There's multiple people.
Like I said.
If the only argument you are going to listen to.
Is still the biggest argument.
There's a fundamental flaw with one of the tasks.
People couldn't get points.
Which they need as survivor.
And therefore they are probably getting eliminated.
Because they didn't get hunter.
That is fundamentally just.
There's nothing to it other than that.
You have a disadvantage that you literally couldn't do.
And then you lose.
And I don't think that's fair for a tournament setting.
I agree with you.
Not the same chance of rolling hunter.
And everybody has the same disadvantage.
It's not about the hunter.
It's about the thing not working.
That's an awful argument to say you had a disadvantage of the thing breaking.
Some people it worked.
If it works for some people it should work for everybody.
So that's a terrible argument.
I also think that the RNG argument is a bit flawed too.
Because in this game the RNG is way different.
Because if you RNG and happen to be a hunter.
Then now congratulations.
You can easily rack up 20 to 30 points this round.
By being a hunter the entire game.
While other people would never have the opportunity to do that.
No matter when they die.
Or when they become a hunter.
Or how many points they tried to get while they were as a bot.
You can never get that many points.
Do I have any Minecraft viewers?
How long do these arguments last?
That's the point of the event.
Because they already sort of figured it out.
I do understand that argument.
I do understand.
The RNG is bad and the game is bad.
As someone in here.
How long do these arguments go?
If it was full skill based.
I should be in the top 20.
Sure, whatever.
I'm not looking forward to playing these games.
I'm not looking forward to getting random targeted by a doll.
Random spawn with a curse.
Random not choosing hunter.
I didn't get the girl for this.
It's a mix of RNG and skill.
People qualified being prop all four times.
And I guarantee you there were people that were hunter.
Starting.
That didn't qualify.
Starting as hunter and then propping three times.
I'm willing to guarantee you.
You'd have to look at a revod.
There's no statistical way.
Exactly.
I would say.
Honestly.
I would put money on the fact that whoever got hunter first round.
Probably made it through.
That's so true.
The 90% minimum.
Didn't you start as hunter first round.
And have zero points.
I started as hunter first round and got 20.
Second round I got zero.
Third round I got five.
Last round I got five.
You started as hunter and got 20 points.
You started as hunter and got 20.
You got more points than I got the entire game.
I was just stealing people's kills.
Yeah, it's still getting a kill.
You were still getting kills though.
Right, exactly.
And then there's a cooldown for you to get kills.
Which is awesome.
There was two rounds I could have got 15 points as the hunter.
But I only got five because you're on a cooldown for a minute.
The problem with the hunter conversation.
They should do bed wars right now.
To settle this.
This is a bed war settlement.
At the end of the day we all knew.
Before the game started that.
Hunting would be.
Everyone's best chance of surviving.
And we just got unlucky.
And I was annoyed.
I got unlucky.
What's the general consensus?
What should happen?
Let's just keep it kind of straight.
More or less.
90% of the people that were in the 40%.
Are probably going to be like.
Yeah, let's just eliminate them.
And then most of the 90% of the 30 people.
Are going to say the same thing.
No, let's just do something again.
No matter what.
People are going to be mad.
Am I on top stream?
You can reboot the screen.
That's mad funny bro.
I'm just here as an outsider.
I don't even go here.
I confirmed using it.
I don't think there is a good solution.
I'm farming right now.
That is insane.
It depends on what the next games are.
Because I don't think playing the doll game again.
Is also a good solution.
No, I agree.
That's my biggest gripe with the solution.
I'm like the audience right now.
I have no idea what's going on in the Minecraft area.
Apparently this is very common.
These types of RNG.
Check me out on YouTube guys.
I'm a YouTube streamer.
I don't play Minecraft.
But I'm checking out on YouTube.
I'm that random VTuber.
They called out.
That made it this far.
That's what comes with it.
It is what it is.
I would hate to be eliminated.
From the game.
If it came down to me not being able to do the chest twice.
Even though I was there and had time to do it.
I think my favorite part is that 5UP made it.
But he is so mad about the chest part.
So he is fighting for the people.
I think that's my favorite.
If you got scuffed by that lag.
Or by that glitch.
Have you send them a clip.
And then do the calculation based off of that.
But there is still the fourth round.
Where people trolled.
Because they thought it was getting restarted.
There was only two props left.
Oh my I should have seen the discord.
The discord beep.
The chat beep.
Was actually crazy.
It was insane.
They are so civilized.
In the voice call.
But the discord fight.
Was insane.
When they are typing.
It was so bad.
People were actually fighting in the chat.
Someone literally responded.
Someone called somebody out.
And then the person responded.
With cry.
I was like woah.
Now.
We will give you back your normal points.
And if you would have made it.
You would have made it.
If you are trying to make it the most balanced.
Which I still think is not balanced.
Because the game is flawed.
The most balanced would be if you genuinely got it.
Bugged.
Either by not getting points for survival.
Or the chest not working.
What is going on?
We are watching a minecraft fight right now.
We are listening into a minecraft fight.
Submitting a clip and having them do all the calculations.
I guess is in theory the most fair way to do it.
Now.
It is still not fair.
I am getting cursed.
It is a big club.
This is a minecraft.
New challenger is here.
I feel like we still have a good 4 minutes left.
There was like 2 people alive.
If you found the person.
Play the 4th round again.
You have to play the 4th round again.
You just could not count that round.
You only got 100 in the 4th round.
Stop it.
Before that round.
Before they said it.
Before they announced it.
Just those 2 people that were left as props.
They are still going.
Apparently this lasts for a while.
I do not know.
Is this what it feels like to be a reaction channel?
I am reacting to stuff live.
I am patient zero.
I am here.
I am in the drama.
Recalculating.
All people.
30 people have to get eliminated.
It is not 30 people going into the doll game.
If they change their mind.
And send the 30 eliminations.
Into the doll game.
Did people leak the chat?
Wait.
What got leaked?
Oh my god.
Are the Latin American streamers mad?
Are they farting?
Was it a Latin American streamer that called out?
Oh my god.
I think the general consensus is.
I don't like survival.
And somebody spamming.
And then.
Organize finals.
I finish it.
I sat there for 30 seconds.
I can make that.
I get eliminated.
Oh my god.
I can immediately be like.
I had to sit there for a minute.
Trying to figure it out.
I could have been hiding somewhere.
And someone said.
Stop being the most annoying.
Who are you?
That happens to people.
Who survive.
We saw that.
That was one of the streamers top.
I think it should be obvious.
That people spam clicks.
Guys what's the leak?
Oh my god guys.
Because that's literally.
Oh my god.
Save.
I almost won that.
I still.
A lot of people.
Are arguing.
Exactly.
On one side.
I don't want to guess, but I am going to guess.
Sam did you not qualify?
I got eliminated.
That's the saddest streamer.
I am just saying.
I am not mad at you.
Obviously, we're going to win.
I'm not against that game.
That's why 90% are going to say both sides.
No, the thing is like you're just saying that.
I actually don't think the game should be replayed at all.
I don't think that should happen.
I don't even know if they should try and do all this shenanigary where they try and fix the eliminations or whatever.
I don't think that's correct or acceptable.
You were just saying things with five of them.
That's why I was like, oh, maybe he's not in.
What I'm saying is that that game was like fundamentally flawed from the beginning, right?
There was never going to be a good outcome by playing that game.
And I think that that was realized by most people round one.
In my VOD, you can go watch my VOD.
In round one, I said, okay, so you cannot win as a prop.
I literally said that.
You cannot win as the prop.
You're not going to win as the prop.
I didn't realize how one-sided it was going to be.
That's actually crazy.
Multiple dramas.
Guys!
I'm so happy I moved to day three.
It should not be true.
When there's money on the line or something, you shouldn't do that to people.
This is what I saw.
You know what I mean?
It could have been stopped round one.
Exactly.
I'm a day three survivor.
I think it's a point though where this is very important.
Where he's saying, you know, the entire event...
Wait!
People turning!
I think it's stupid!
Oh my God!
That's crazy!
At this point, putting us all into the doll game tomorrow, 70 people, is like putting us in a blender.
Oh my God!
Right.
I don't think that's fair.
I don't think they should do something where...
10 % of the people that survive this time will probably get eliminated.
I'm going to be honest.
If they do the doll game tomorrow and I get eliminated because of it, I'll be pissed.
Don't worry.
We can think it's not fair, but it's literally the point of how they designed the event and how they designed the game.
Bro, people have to turn on the webcam to argue!
I can't let random VTubers have a chance to argue!
These games have had significantly more randomness than other potential rivals that have existed right in the past.
Like the 2021 Minecraft Rivals.
Right.
Rivals is always scuffed in RNG.
The point of this event is the RNG.
I think you guys are getting mixed up.
There's multiple different types of RNG.
All the other events that we've done so far is a different type of RNG to this.
Yes, I agree 100%.
It's completely unbalanced RNG.
It's RNG that everyone is going through, but this is not.
But if you're in the doll game, there's a group of 30 people running into a hallway and there's a doll in front of it.
You can still...
I disagree with that.
The only part in the doll game that was unfair is the spawn.
If you were right next to the yellow blonde doll...
That's insane!
Bro!
The fact that staff actually antagonized the Latin American...
The fact that staff actually antagonized the Spanish speaking streamers...
That's so crazy!
Do we revive Red Velvet because he couldn't do anything against that blonde dude?
Oh my god!
Bro!
Did they not learn what happened in Rust?
Do you guys remember the great Rust wars?
That was a crazy drama!
But we're not talking about reviving Red now.
Oh my god!
Just give me Rust memories.
Even with the RNG of today...
I'll be fully honest.
I got Hunter round 1 and that obviously gave me a buff.
What was that?
There was a similar situation and why Rust is now divided and now different.
In the past, Rust would invite separate communities together.
It got really bad for one of them.
To the point where they don't do that anymore for Rust.
That's why they don't do Rust Twitch Rivals anymore.
Yeah,
the Rust Twitch Rivals.
This is basically the Rust Twitch Rivals.
It was stupid.
I will agree.
The Hunter thing was just dumb but we all knew it going into it.
90% of the people here probably had an idea that maybe we should just die right away and just respawn.
I got 25 of my 30 points from just being...
I never purposely killed myself.
I never got to be a Hunter and I still survived.
I only killed one person.
Yeah, I never actually killed myself either and I made it fine.
I did have one round as Hunter.
It was possible.
My first round I got was no points and so it was fine.
Yeah, sure, you gotta be a Hunter but there's people that survive.
Again, would random VTuber number 13 survive being a Hunter?
Like a Hider three or four times?
No.
Look, I'm not like...
What I'm gonna say, I don't want everyone to think that I'm saying that I need to change my mind.
Here's the thing though, I was propped four times, right?
It was impossible for me to have ever won the game.
I literally could never win the game.
The first two rounds I could not get any points because I couldn't run around.
Oh my god, how could you?
I'm not just random VTuber number 13.
I'm random VTuber number one.
You probably figured the map out better.
There's probably a bit of a skill difference, right?
You figured the map out better.
If you were gonna be a Hunter, you would have probably survived.
Right, that's what I'm saying.
If I'd been a Hunter, I would have definitely survived, bro.
If I'd got the hunt.
Yeah, 100%.
100%.
I agree.
What I'm saying is that I don't know, the idea that...
I also just... the idea that like...
Bro, who has their webcam on again?
And then people losing will be upset.
People that got eliminated today can make the same argument, right?
Like if you're saying oh, if they redo it tomorrow and then I get eliminated, I'm gonna be mad.
Then how could you ever say that if somebody said, oh, today's game was complete bull, and they're mad.
How could you ever disagree with them?
You're basically agreeing by saying that you would be mad if you got eliminated tomorrow.
Right, right, right.
The counter to that kind of is like...
Like I was saying earlier, besides the glitchy things, we all knew that it was dumb.
Like we all knew going into the game, the points, how it was gonna run, what points we would get where.
I agree with the point of like that people that didn't get points because of being buggy is fundamentally the problem.
That's the number one problem in this whole entire thing, and them calling it early.
The reason that like, if I was to have lost and whatever, get a second chance, I'd feel like I was lucky because I knew going into the game that I had to just rage that I'd get RNG Hunter, and if I didn't, I'd probably get eliminated.
Yeah, I mean that's basically what I'm saying.
Yeah, it's true.
We can all agree Hunter was bullshit!
Like, why are we still arguing about this?
Like, why are we still arguing about Hunter?
We all know it's bullshit.
If you did it three times, then you would've been eliminated if it just didn't work for you.
You would've been at risk.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying too.
What's the word?
If then we were to give people points for that too, right?
I could literally say the same thing of just being like, oh, I spent 40 seconds doing it, so I could've survived if I had been hiding instead, you know what I mean?
What's your guys' consensus right now?
Nothing.
Is this something that we're...
Okay.
What is the consensus after arguing about this?
Probably not.
We're just yelling at each other for no reason.
Unless there's an actual...
What's the point?
I just want to know...
I want you guys to answer some questions for me just because I'm curious, not that this would affect literally anything.
What is the problem with the doll game?
The problem with the doll game is if you spawn next to the...
There are set spawn points when the doll actually spawns itself.
If you spawned next to that spawn point of the yellow doll or other dolls, it's going to fundamentally seek you and the other people can just run just on spawn points.
There's nothing you can do.
If you change the spawn points to where that's where you voted and that's where you were going to start instead of your set spawn, that helps a lot.
The only flaw then becomes the final round.
Where does the doll spawn?
When the entire circle is the same color.
Let's say the last round is that blonde doll and you happen to be right where it spawns.
It's just going to immediately speed 20 at you and kill you.
The problem is too if we do the doll game again and we don't have that blonde one, we will be waiting for three hours for everyone to die because it already took long enough with the other ones and we survive sometimes with the other ones.
If we don't have that random RNG effect to it, skill will come into a factor and we'll all just survive.
What if they give you longer grace period?
Are you Minecrafters?
Guys, we're getting intel for the next event!
The problem is it seems like the things don't move.
They move randomly until they get close enough and then they start hunting.
If they wait two seconds, we're all going to be sitting in corners for a minute waiting for them to randomly walk into our hallway and then attack us.
There were multiple rounds during doll game that I'm running at the front of the group.
I ran into the doll and because of the way the doll A.Y.
works, you can just turn around immediately and pass your hitbox past someone else's and it will never target you.
If the doll takes five seconds to hit you, they're so mad that random Vtuber number 13 made it here.
I don't understand why I got brought up two to three times.
Bro, I'm sorry for eliminating I'm sorry for eliminating your fellow Minecraft players.
Why not just put people in that like hot potato game and let like I guess people can't be added to tomorrow.
I mean, that would basically be the same thing as the one game, right?
Do you guys know this random Vtuber streams on YouTube?
At least with hot potato, I can find Feinberg and try and give him a potato all game.
Oh my god, they're laughing now!
They're reconnecting!
The people agree that if they reviewed the vods and added in the points for
for survival slash Well, I mean, obviously they're going to do that, right?
Like, obviously they're going to do that.
Like, that has to be done.
Like, if there were survival points or a bug or like if people tried to do things They won't do anything about this game if they're just gonna have us all survive tomorrow.
Obviously, I think we already know that's not happening.
That's not going to occur.
That's what they said.
I don't expect That's what they said right now.
Right now, that's what I'm planning for.
That we're playing that game tomorrow.
That's what I'm planning for.
And obviously, like, I think the best thing is, like, if that happens, we all just like, accept it.
Go GG.
Like, GG go next.
Oh my god, they're finally accepting it.
I don't know, like, not have a rift be between us as players.
That was literally what I said at the end of my stream.
I was like, at the end of the day like, it's a game.
We were playing a game.
Nobody should be mad at anybody.
Nobody should be, like, hating on other people.
Like, it's a game.
Like, we're playing a game.
Yes, it was definitely dumb, but, I mean, it's just a game.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys!
Right, exactly.
It changes the dynamic when there's 70k online or whatever.
Friendship wins, guys!
And then the game is super RNG or whatever.
It's like, definitely changes the vibe and is very tilting.
Like, when you feel like you can't do anything.
We're finally agreeing that it's RNG!
What I was trying to say earlier, Sam, even though, like, you said you don't care.
And I'm not saying this now to, like, say that you do care or anything like that.
It's like, the people that do care that will be eliminated today will be mad.
And if we switch it, the people that did survive are gonna be mad.
Not at specific people.
Like, I'm not mad at anyone here.
But, like, someone is gonna be mad.
Guys, we went through a character arc, guys!
No matter what they choose to do, we're just gonna have to deal with it.
And if you're pissy, just don't play another Rivals, I guess.
I don't know.
Yeah, I mean, 30 people gone to dull RNG or 30 people gone to that game though?
Right, exactly.
That's the question, right?
That's what it comes down to.
Are we killing 30 people to a game that was the Hunter game or just to Dull game, right?
They have to kill 30 people.
Right, I agree.
I think the Dull game was completely unbalanced the whole time.
I had a goaded spawn.
I spawned in green and, like, the Dulls were spawning on the opposite half the entire game, so I just got to run away at the beginning for free.
I mean, that's just...
But there's strategy to that, like, if I will agree that I just, like, sent everyone around to Sapnap.
I was like, Sapnap, just yell at everyone to go on to the other side and listen to him.
And the Dull always just spawned on the other side because Sapnap just screamed.
And then, like, that skill to where that's why, like, me and Feinberg didn't have to worry about anything.
The power of friendship.
The good ending.
What a twist.
If we're talking about, like, unfairness in any game in every single thing, whatever, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Someone like Red would have been unfairly killed because there was just physically nothing they could have done.
I watched Red's POV.
He could have gone on the other door because he ran for a more secure door is the only argument I have for that.
There is a thing he could have done.
He also didn't find any safe zone just in the area he was running.
That's the only argument, but there was something he could have done technically.
And that same thought process is that there could have been other things.
There was not anything people could have done, technically, for a chest not working.
Just not doing it.
They could have gotten more points from the rest of the game.
I mean, what they could have done is...
Probably VOD reviewing, guys.
I told you Minecraft streamers are on a whole other level.
Especially speedrunners.
Here's the thing, though.
Is that...
Yeah, they're VOD reviewing.
How do they have time to VOD review?
This guy literally VOD reviewed in the middle of between games.
The hunter one round, they just probably got a billion points because the spawn time was like one and a half minutes.
The spawn time should have been consistent.
The only way to fix the game is this.
Everyone should have got a turn to be the hunter.
Everyone should have had turns that they were not the hunter.
Everyone should have got one turn to be the hunter.
That way everybody gets a chance to be hunter.
What's going on?
We're listening to the Minecraft debate.
You should just have the same respawn time across all four rounds.
For those who are FPS gamers, this is a whole new level for us.
This is how arguments should be.
Instead of like...
You have an advantage over the hunter, even.
Let alone the people who are the props.
You have a way big advantage.
I've never experienced this before.
There's a cooldown timer.
That's all because there's a cooldown on killing.
I'm literally in a debate class right now.
They're being a cooldown for respawning.
When you spam cooldowns like this into a game, it leads to situations where inherently this terrible gameplay emerges.
It's civil, but nothing is being agreed upon.
They probably should have told us about it.
One of the organizers came in and was like, so what did you guys agree on?
And then some other guy was like, nothing.
And I sat here for 40 minutes listening to how to argue.
I'm trying to hide, right?
So I have no idea that bro can't kill me right now.
What I should do is run away.
I have no idea of that.
But again, that's part of the game, right?
That's part of the game is you don't know everything.
Some people turned their webcams on.
That was crazy.
I said that as a joke.
About how to turn the webcam on, look inside to debate.
Some people actually did that.
I was like, oh my god.
This is serious.
People were saying, oh, it's one minute and a half.
We knew that stuff sucked.
The kill cooldown stuff was stupid.
We should have known that.
Everything that was knowledge that we knew.
Once you've played around, if you figured out all the stuff were in the same spots every single time, that's just knowledge.
The biggest problem with that game is that people weren't getting points because the thing was buggy.
Inherently, the only problem.
If you didn't get Hunter, that RNG starts to be you.
This feels like a court trial.
You can still survive if you did this or that.
But inherently, if you didn't get Hunter, it is LU at that point.
Every game in this whole entire event and continue to be will probably have some type of dumb RNG that if you don't get it Call me out right now.
Your head is going to explode.
I don't know.
Call me out.
Call out the random YouTuber.
The last game to decide who wins this event could be like Oh, does your name start with the letter F?
Oh, congratulations, you win for $70,000.
This guy coded it from above.
You hear that?
This guy is cheating.
Inherently, the games coming up too could be problematic too.
And what are we going to do for every single game?
I think the only reason that I feel like they need to do something about this game was because everyone knew during round one that the game was just scuffed.
It was just a scuffed game.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what should have happened is the rivals people should have said, wait a minute, this doesn't make any sense.
Look at the disparity in the points already after a singular round.
We know that some people are just getting eliminated basically off round one, round two, automatic.
Having these people call her events scuffed, I feel so bad.
She has been listening to this.
They were in the call.
He dipped out.
The game is never tested in a way where like, we got 70k on the line.
I agree with that.
The fact that there's 70k on the line and the games weren't as well tested as it was.
Because like, I've had to test games out before.
The fact that like they didn't test the games enough with the quantity of people.
Hear me out, Twitch Rivals, if you're hearing this, if Twitch Rivals offered me a job to make sure their events weren't dumb, I would do that than playing this.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, but would you do it for free?
To like, make sure that like their things are fair, and do something like that.
Offer people 10 bucks to just play their game for an hour, and then give feedback.
Oh yeah, 100%.
Twitch Rivals, do you hear that?
If they weren't gonna do the doll game thing.
How did more people join back?
I thought people left.
Yeah, if they didn't do the doll game, they'd have to give the survival points to people, and then give back the points that people randomly killed their points by punching random things.
Does everyone agree that that's better than the doll game?
Yeah, a million percent.
I'm pretty sure every single person would agree.
Yeah, well I mean, obviously that game's dumber than the doll game.
Obviously.
Someone was just saying like, the fix instead of playing another game tomorrow should just be to have people open a ticket if they genuinely experienced a bug or trolled at the end of the last one after they said it was cancelled.
That's what I think too.
That's the only way to do it.
I think if the staff knew that most people agree on something, they can make a better decision.
Obviously not to tell them what to do, but I feel like everybody prefers that over the doll game and probably even some people who got eliminated would agree.
Just give us $500!
I don't care anymore!
Calculate those completely bugged points.
To be clear, I don't want to come back tomorrow from whatever, and then I'm one of the people who got eliminated.
I don't want to come start streaming tomorrow and start playing Rival.
And then I immediately die.
I don't understand.
Because the way they worded it is kind of disambiguous as well.
And they're discordant about that.
I agree.
I think that the only way they can do anything that's remotely fair is to take all of the streams and everyone who says that they didn't get points they should have got and to fix their points and then see who the 30 were or whatever.
People can lie!
Oh wait, no, there's clips.
Then that was how the game should have eliminated you, right?
So that's just the only fair way.
It's not fair because people can just say this weird word.
And the points that people said that they were throwing.
Sure, yeah.
You should get those back.
The only reason they should get those points back is because they said they were rewriting the game.
Yeah, exactly.
If they say they're rewriting the game, then everything is up in the air at that point, basically.
I stopped nobbing as a hunter because I thought it was over.
So that should have been 5 points.
My chest was broken!
That's another 5 points.
That's 10 points right there.
If they only had 5 points, you know what I mean?
Bro, that's 10 points!
I stopped nobbing!
I stopped nobbing, you guys!
You were all there!
There might be someone that was The chest was broken, I got laughed at by my chat.
I should get 15 points to justify my mental To justify my mental deterioration from my chat laughing at me because I thought I fucked up.
I deserve 15 points for that.
I thought I was so stupid that I couldn't turn the chest.
And I saw my chat laughing at me that I couldn't open the chest.
At the end of the day, none of us can get mad at each other.
If Rival decides to do a doll game, we shut our mouths and just play the doll game.
If they eliminate 30 people, if you get eliminated, you survive.
Fine, 5 day event starting tomorrow.
Fine, just start it over.
What was the point of this argument?
If we're just gonna settle with what was originally agreed upon.
No one should get mad at each other.
Us players should get mad at each other.
The only person to be frustrated at is the people who allowed the game to be played like that.
That's exactly what I said at the end of my stream as well.
Nobody should be upset.
If we did the doll game tomorrow, and I get eliminated, I'd be pretty mad.
It always will be an issue with Rivals.
I understand.
Nothing happened.
They just argued.
This is always an inherent issue with them.
They just argued for the sake of arguing.
It just went with their original intent.
Having any pieces of RNG and random factors that could boost a random player to do better.
What kind of drops is there for Minecraft?
The problem with that is that inherently for money, we all want to try our best.
Oh, another thing I just learned.
I don't even know if this conversation is still going.
Sorry to interrupt.
The Hunters, this wasn't said in the rules.
The Hunters, if you kill a person, you were at a minute cooldown where you couldn't kill anybody.
Yeah, we already talked about that.
If there was multiple rounds, I would have gotten like 15 points.
There was two rounds in a row.
I don't know why that wouldn't be...
They should have said that in the rules.
Well, in round one, I already said I was getting stood on by a guy that was on kill cooldown and I had no idea.
That chest with the key, there was just one of them standing in front of there and I was like, I'm going to get these five points just to get these five points and if he kills me afterwards, oh well.
And he just looked at me.
And I was like, alright, my guy.
Like, thanks, I guess.
Alright, bye.
And I left.
Once I realized that I killed someone and I had kill cooldown, I realized that now that guy probably just literally couldn't kill me.
Yeah.
But that's a...
They should have put that in the rules.
That's really weird that they didn't add the cooldown stuff to the rules.
But inherently, that was a part of the game and that's like, I mean, sucks to be you if you could have gotten a triple combo.
I guess.
Jesus Christ.
I thought the hitboxes were cooked or something and then after round three, I realized, oh, there's just a cooldown.
I didn't see it, but there is.
Yeah, I mean, I think that the number one mistake is a classic Twitch Rivals move and the number one mistake is that at the end of the game, they said that they were going to redo the game, which they should not have.
The fact that they said before the game ended that they were going to redo things...
Classic Rivals move.
My immediate thought, even though I was a hunter every single time, because I was like, going into the third... end of the third round, I was still... I never was a hunter.
I was out of the bottom 30 and I was like, perfect, I'm surviving, cool, whatever.
And then I did my two challenges and then I was like, okay, I'm at 30 points, awesome, I think I'll be fine.
And then immediately when they said, oh yeah, by the way, did something count?
I was immediately like, well, I was probably going to survive and now I'm not.
Again, I mean, if they end up choosing to do whatever they want tomorrow, that's their choice and whatever.
And if I lose in the doll game tomorrow, if they end up doing that, I mean...
Oh well, you know, GG, I guess.
No, for 50 minutes, everybody just accepted it.
Did everyone have fun today?
Yeah, it was fun.
I like to hang out with all my friends.
It was so fun to play, even if it didn't really function all that well.
I've never been more stressed in a Minecraft event ever in my life before playing this dumb, stupid, stinky event.
Bro, did we just go through the 5 stages of grief for Minecraft players?
Did Minecraft players just go through the stages of grief?
Bro, what was the point?
What was the point of this?
Like I said earlier, there's never going to be an answer at least that makes everyone happy.
There will be 5, 10, 20 people on either side that will be pissed tomorrow.
Or whenever they make their final decision.
They've hit the acceptance stage.
Acceptance has been reached.
If it works in your favor, if it doesn't.
Automatically, what ends up happening, whenever there's a problem, immediately the people that were going to get eliminated are going to be like, yes, please, do it again.
And then the people that survived are obviously going to be like, no, please don't.
Like, I want to win 70 grand.
Bro, no, I just wanted $500.
You got to think about like, inherently what the idea of this whole entire event was supposed to be.
like Are you sure for D4?
Like that we're trying to do that one code thing.
Ended up trying to do it all four rounds.
That's kind of on them.
No offense, that's kind of on them.
I'm not saying they did.
I just thought it was stupid.
Or you thought it was broken.
Why are you doing it more than once?
I didn't know, I just thought it hit.
If those people, if they got five extra points and survived, I'd be like, yeah.
Like, I'd be upset.
But if they had like zero points going into the last round, or like zero points just in general, you were going to get out even if you did do that four times.
Like, you know what I mean?
Damn.
That's not me.
I don't know, my chat laughed at me.
If people survived five minutes and didn't get points for that too, they should get those points and then calculate, see what they get.
And if people survived because of it, W.
If you don't, you probably wouldn't have survived anyways.
Wow.
I mean, he's not wrong.
I am surprised I made it this far.
I'm surprised I got it here.
That just means tomorrow we get to play three games if we play the dog game.
Hey, isn't that fun?
Yay.
Guys, my voice still messed up.
What do you think?
Sorry, I'll meet up again.
Okay.
You don't have to meet up.
No, please do.
I don't want to hear you.
I've been sick for the past three days.
Alright, guys, I think debate's over.
Do you think the debate is over?
Can we leave now?
Hey, game's game.
Wow.
Bro, what?
Bro, that was that was crazy.
That's actually crazy.
During the entire time, I ordered soup.
I ordered a sandwich.
I caught a genesect on Poke Road.
Bro, I was just listening in.
That was actually insane.
Does this happen often in Minecraft?
Girl, I don't fucking know.
Bro, the fact that they debated for more than an hour straight, but then they had zero, it just went back in a circle.
They agreed to nothing.
They actually, they just accepted.
That was crazy.
There was one part I did tune back in and then I heard Fyva say some shit like, guys, actually there was something they did tell us that's for Hunters that Hunters had a one minute cooldown.
And everyone in Unison said we talked about that.
That's so true, yeah.
Yeah, that was so true.
That was so fucking funny.
Oh my god.
That was actually crazy.
I was so surprised.
I was like, what am I listening to?
Oh my god.
Everyone in Unison, they already told us.
Did you see the fight?
Did you see the tweets they linked?
That was linked to us?
Yeah.
I can't believe the Discord got leaked.
They leaked it on stream.
Did you know that?
Yeah, I saw that shit.
Bro, they actually, we're talking about the callouts, the Discord fight.
The Discord chat fight.
And people were leaking the chat logs on stream.
Not us, we're just telling you guys.
We didn't call out who it was, but we were just like, oh my god, people are fighting.
Some people were actually, some streamers that were participating in this Twitch Rivals actually leaked the Discord chat logs on stream.
It was crazy.
Man.
Bro, I'm glad we made it to day three, Goomy.
We would've missed out.
Yeah.
Are you coming back for day four?
Yeah, I'll see you tomorrow.
Let's play the dog game again.
I'm gonna win.
It has to be the dog game.
That was like one of the most stressful ones.
It'll be okay.
We're gonna win.
I'll see you on day four, Goomy.
Wait, what?
What?
I'll see you on day four, Goomy.
Goomy, I just went through.
Goomy, the stream could've ended two hours ago.
Vtuber number 13?
Hey, that's me.
I kept getting called out like three times.
I feel like they're like this Vtuber should not have made it this far but because of RNG.
She's here too.
That was so fucking good.
They mentioned you like multiple times.
What the fuck did I do?
I'm sorry I got in because of RNG.
She eliminated.
I'm gonna talk to my chat.
Goomy, please.
I'll play Valorant tomorrow, Goomy.
Okay!
Bye, Goomy!
Bye-bye!
Alright, guys.
Alright, that was wild.
That was actually wild.
I did not expect today's Minecraft day to be like this.
I did not expect.
Day four.
We're back with day four.
No way.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
There's multiple fights going on right now.
And I'm just like this random Vtuber number 13 looking in the sidelines being like what the hell is going on?
What the fuck is...
Zap is trending on Twitter because of the leaks.
We listened in to a fucking Minecraft debate for an hour.
Oh my god.
Also, I only streamed the call because everybody else was streaming the call anyway.
So I was like, alright.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
It was pretty civilized though.
It was pretty civilized though for a debate about a game.
I think my favorite part was when they ended it with like did you guys have fun?
After people were like mad.
Did you guys have fun?
Oh my god.
For those who are new here, welcome to my channel.
We're not a drama channel.
We just got roped in.
I'm literally not a Minecraft player.
I got invited to the Minecraft Twitch Rivals and I was like, that's fun.
I think I'm one of the few streamers that are not part of the Minecraft community that's made it this far.
That's still in it because there's not a lot of us left.
There's definitely not a lot of us left.
By the way, please check me out on YouTube.
I usually stream on Twitch when it comes to Twitch events which was this event.
That's why I'm here.
Check me out on YouTube.
You guys want to know when I stream on Twitch?
It'll be like tomorrow at 12pm same time.
I will be on I would usually tweet out whenever
I'm streaming on Twitch.
So please follow me on Twitter.
I heard that my YouTube's figure is up now.
I don't know if it's up for pre-order now.
I don't know if my mod has made a command for it or anything.
But yes, I will tweet out the announcement for my YouTube's figure.
It came out during the middle of all of this.
So I couldn't.
Oh, it opens for pre-orders on the 11th.
Sorry, it opens for pre-orders on the 11th.
So yeah, I'll tweet that out later.
Sorry, in the midst of all this drama I couldn't.
It's Minecraft drama.
The thing is, it's Minecraft drama.
The thing about Minecraft drama is that there's drama almost every week to the point where people are going to forget about it so soon.
I swear, even somebody who's not even part of the Minecraft community, I always see Minecraft drama.
So I feel like there's always stuff happening.
There's always stuff happening, so like I'm not surprised.
So yeah, that was like...
That was fun.
Anyway, guys.
Yeah, had a great time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
What a rest week, guys.
What a rest week.
The people on YouTube sure are missing out right now.
Did not expect Minecraft drama.
I ran for this event to lead this way.
Hey, guys.
See you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!